make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and as
i was sitting here thinking about this i
was like you know i could do the aliens
comics but the more i think about this
because i asked you guys a question
previously like what stories i hadn't
finished that you guys wanted me to
finish up and
people said dark side war they were like
finished dark side work here's the thing
i made dark side war back when my video
sucked and so i was like you know what
if we're gonna finish it we might as
well remaster it right so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna remaster dark
side war and i promise this one won't
suck as much as the last one did
so here's the thing to understand about
dark side war dark side war was the
event that led into dc rebirth and it
was basically dc kind of
you know pruning a lot of the things and
adjusting a lot of the things and
setting the stage for a lot of things
one of the other important concepts to
understand here with dark side war
is that some of the stuff that we see
does not apply anymore that a lot of
this not really a lot but some of it was
changed
during the events of dark knight's medal
and death metal
and scott snyder's justice league run so
uh i will go ahead and make sure that we
know what information stays what
information goes as we're going through
this story
but when it comes to dark side world
we're initially going to start with
issue number 40. now this whole video is
going to be issues 40 through 45 for
those of you guys who want to keep track
or buy it online or something like that
it's called dark side war act 1.
for issue number 40 there's not really a
whole lot that matters here i mean we're
kind of given a little bit of
information but it's things that you
know things we already know for the most
part for example
uh scot-free is the son of high father
on new genesis
and for example that like metron
brokered a peace between new genesis and
the planet apocalypse where darkseid
resides
different things like that you know just
just that kind of situation what does
matter and really
the big takeaway that came from issue
number 40 from the very beginnings of
all this
is the anti-monitor mobius now initially
we didn't know the anti-monitor had a
name and in fact we didn't even really
know that he had any kind of personality
or anything
all we really knew about the
anti-monitor is what we got in the
events of crisis on infinite earth and
infinite crisis when the anti-monitor
was responsible for the destruction of
the multiverse and then we returned
during the events of infinite crisis and
sinestro core war when he joined the
forces of sinestro but this was a huge
change a huge departure for his
character because one it's established
his name is mobius
and two he was the reason for the
destruction of the earth 3 universe now
as part of the lead
up to the events of dark side war you
got a story called forever evil and
forever evil was basically this story
where the crime syndicate of america
which was an alternate reality version
of the justice league where all the
heroes are bad guys
where they had basically fled their
universe and showed up in the main dc
universe that was the whole basis behind
the forever evil event we didn't really
know exactly why that happened and when
dark side war took place when that
started up this gave us the explanation
that in effect uh mobius had shown up to
the earth 3 universe and basically
eradicated all the life on that on that
world
and then in turn had absorbed all of his
energies into himself and so the big
thing that kind of comes out of this and
kind of what we're told here when metron
encounters mobius and a really good way
to view metron is kind of like the dc
universe version of the watcher to a
degree i mean he's not as powerful as
like the watcher in marvel and even in
and of himself
he's not wildly capable uh he is and so
far is the fact that he's a new god so
like
you know he's stronger than your average
bear but uh and you know with the the
chair that he has the the mobius chair
that's what makes him so capable is
because the person who sits in the
mobius chair
has all knowledge of everything that's
currently going on in the universe and
everything that has happened in the
universe
and so one of the things that happens is
that when metron encounters and really
comes across mobius he initially tells
them like you can't do this
right like i know what it is that you're
shooting for i know what it is that
you're trying to do
do not do this because i know what fate
awaits you you're going to call down the
power of dark side
and dark side is going to lead to your
destruction not only that the war that
you're trying to instigate here between
yourself and dark side
this is going to lead to the end of the
of of the universe it's going to lead to
the end of reality and one of the things
that's kind of hit on here in dark side
war is that
because we got events like crisis on
invented earth and zero hour crisis in
time and infinite crisis and final
crisis and
even the main new 52 event because of
the fact that we got so many different
crisis events that basically rewrote the
universe if another one were to happen
the the universe and even
the multiverse wouldn't be able to
survive it would all just basically be
destroyed there'd be no way to save it
because
one thing to understand is that in the
previous crisis events it was more or
less restructuring reality is really
what it was it was like remodeling your
home
what metron's talking about here is that
if another crisis were to happen it'd be
like blowing your home up right that's
more or less what he's what he's
offering here what he's saying here at
the end of the day though
mobius doesn't care right he's looking
to attain the power
really attain a way to kind of go back
to the way he was before to undo this
hellish life that he's living now we are
given a bit of an explanation
and really kind of a lot of an
explanation in terms of why he is the
way he is
uh what it is that powers him and this
his whole motivation behind this war but
we don't find out until the end so
uh it kind of sucks it kind of sucks in
that way
but one of the things is that where
metron initially tries to stop him
ultimately he's overpowered by mobius
and mobius basically says like i want a
war with dark side that's what i'm
shooting for and so the big thing that
the other big thing that came out of
this is that following metron being
overpowered you end up having the
appearance of this kind of mystery woman
that seems to be operating
you know along the lines of mobius
helping him to achieve this goal now
that's all basically prelude stuff the
meat and potatoes this picks up when you
have a woman who shows up in her
apartment by the name of marina black uh
for those of you guys who are also
wondering this art is by a guy named
jason feybach it is amazing isn't it but
kanto's basically there along with
lashina waiting for this woman to get
home
they asked her are you marina black and
when she responds like yeah but like
where's my husband at they kill her
now this turns out that it's not the
marina black they're hunting for and
they're actually looking for a very
particular woman
it's almost like terminator right you
know he's just looking for a very
particular woman
and it makes sense to just go through
and kill every version they find until
they ultimately kill the one they're
looking for now a little bit of
explanation here
uh lashina is part of a group called the
furies and kanto is an assassin for dark
side uh the furies are almost like
darkseid's kind of elite guard composed
almost entirely of women there are men
who are furious but you don't really see
them all that often uh but lashina is
one of the best she's not the absolute
best
but she's one of the best but what this
does is it switches over to a guy by the
name of scot-free now scot-free
is also known as mr miracle and kind of
referencing our discussion
on metron brokering peace between
apocalypse and new genesis
because they kind of represent the idea
of like absolute good and absolute evil
even though
new genesis kind of stretches the limits
of credulity when it comes to truly
being good
uh what this basically meant was that
they had to switch sons right so uh the
son of darkseid went over to
uh went over to new genesis and his name
is orion the son of high father who was
named scot-free was sent to apocalypse
now unlike orion who lived on new
genesis who lived a pretty great life
and ultimately became a hero
scot-free was basically thrown into the
slave pits by by darkseid
and just left there the result is it
became a master at being able to pick
all manner of locks and so that's why
he's called mr miracle he's kind of the
escape artist of the dc universe because
there's no lock in the universe that he
cannot pick
but the thing here is that him kind of
going around and bouncing around and
sort of being free to a degree he's
ultimately hunting for what it is that
darkseid's trying to achieve because
word has reached his ears the dark side
is shooting for a particular goal and so
the result of this is that once he ends
up grabbing one of the mother boxes and
it kind of spills the beans on what dark
side's shooting for he begins to panic
right he's kind of like okay
like this can't be possible something
has to be done right so a lot of mystery
going on
in this this first little tidbit here
now from there we switch over to an
investigation that's taking place with
the justice league this is not
overly important it kind of is to a
degree because it sort of furthers the
story a little bit but it's a little
more character development than anything
else this first part is really just kind
of designed to show us
what the different people are doing at
different points in time uh but we do
have jessica cruz here and for those of
you guys who are not familiar with
jessica cruz
she was introduced as part of the
forever evil event and then just sort of
kept moving forward with dc comics and
the idea is that her whole writing
experience or the whole idea behind
creating her character
is that she's someone who's kind of
riddled with anxiety and depression and
so in a lot of ways it seemed to sort of
mirror to a degree the struggle of jeff
johns and even more so the struggle of
sam humphries a writer who was who's
amazing in everything he touches but the
idea is that from the earth 3 syndicate
you had their version of the green
lantern called power ring unlike hal
jordan in the main dc universe
power ring was just a coward uh but the
ring itself would constantly talk to him
and influence him now for those of you
guys who follow the green lantern mythos
you guys know
it was essentially both doom if you
don't know what that means you can find
out more about that in the green lantern
playlist that we have
but in essence the ring of jessica cruz
is possessed by a malevolent entity
is really all you need to know but she
was very much just kind of controlled by
her anxiety to a degree right it
dominated every facet of her life
her evolution as power ring in dc comics
was designed to show
or really kind of represent the struggle
of a person overcoming their anxiety
things like that becoming a much
stronger person and finding their inner
strength right so that's why she's here
it's the reason why if you've never
heard of her as a green lantern it's
because
at the time this story was written she
was exceedingly new but again there's
not a whole lot doing here in this this
early tidbit right just a few things
here and there some some
you know little indications of what
people are doing and and so on and so
forth the big thing about this
is that when you have the justice league
conducting their investigation
that because cyborg is a living computer
and can tap into the various
intelligence satellites and things like
that he begins to pick up on a pattern
and what he starts to realize
is that there have been these various
murders taking place across the united
states basically the murders of women
named marina black and so because that
he realized
somebody's tracking her down they're
looking for a very particular person who
that person is
the justice league doesn't know but in
the middle of all this suddenly out of
nowhere
hands just like emerge from the mouth of
barry allen and like this
girl just pulls herself out right this
mystery girl working for darkseid just
pulls herself out now the reality is
we know this girl is grail right we know
that the nature of our character kind of
looking at this in hindsight but
suspension of disbelief let's imagine
that we're five or six years ago in dc
comics and we don't know
the cool thing is that as soon as she
emerges she immediately overpowers the
justice league like
right off the bat like batman cyborg all
these guys they're all
immediately overpowered by this girl
even shazam falls before the power of
the squirrel now she doesn't
kill them all she just overpowers them
the crazy thing is that of course
wonder woman jumps into the fray and
wonder woman you know this girl
basically reveals that she's of amazon
blood so she in some form or fashion
hails from themyscira which is kind of a
crazy thing it's not uncommon it's not
the first
time that we've seen some mystery woman
out there in the dc universe who hails
from themyscira who we've never heard of
before dc's done that like two or three
times before
usually it's only confined to the wonder
woman mythos sometimes it's the justice
league as a whole but the important
thing is that following that while while
she basically incapacitates the entirety
of the justice league we switch over to
superman and lex luthor now superman is
currently attending with lex because for
the most part lex luthor is currently a
good guy and the reason why
is because of the events of forever evil
the following the forever evil story
that lex luthor had kind of reworked
himself and when the heroes were
incapacitated
during that event by the crime syndicate
lex luthor led a contingent of villains
and kind of reformed them into becoming
heroes in order to save the world
following that some of the villains went
back to being villains most of them
stayed heroes that's why you have
captain cold here different things like
that but the reason why superman lex
luthor are together here is because of
the fact that there
is a former villain or at least a
villain at one time named neutron who's
currently lost his powers now that goes
into the amazon event it's not overly
important for our discussion here the
important thing is that neutron has the
ability to absorb like nuclear radiation
to use it for his own ends the good
thing about this is that when you have
the ability to do that you can achieve
all kinds of stuff
light super strength different things
like that the downside is that when your
body loses the power to process nuclear
radiation
it turns into cancer and so because of
that neutrons basically dying
now of course superman pulls a little
bit of a rare psychology manages to kind
of get lex luthor to sort of cure the
cancer on his own but in the middle of
all that
uh they're suddenly met by a
communication from diana saying like we
need your help right there's some girl
who's literally wrecking us
and so when lex luthor dawns his new
outfit in order to
you know travel with superman to face
off against wonder woman lex luthor's
sister pulls a gun on him and then
basically shoots him and then uses a
mother box and teleports both of them
directly to apocalypse and so following
that they're kind of out of commission
and so with
grail single-handedly taking out or at
least temporarily incapacitating
the entirety of the justice league she
in turn casts an inscription or
incantation on the ground
which is designed to summon doomsday she
also in turn takes the ring of jessica
cruz
because it's possessed by volthume and
uses the power within to basically
create a portal from this universe
into the earth 3 universe that summons
the anti-monitor and so at the moment
what she's done here is she's basically
brought anti-monitor to earth which is
what the anti-monitor wanted
and then she basically sends out an sos
a beacon that dark side will pick up on
and then dark side will travel to and so
because of that what you end up doing is
you switch over to scot-free and where
scott free was initially involved in a
bit of a conflict between kanto and
lucina when he
ultimately tracked down one of the women
named marina black of course not the one
they're hunting for
he uses mother box and then teleported
them away along with himself
and then when he arrived at his
destination he met the real marina black
the one that everybody's currently
hunting for now marina black as she's
given to us and as this explained here
she is in effect in amazon the idea
behind this is that marina black
basically states that at some point in
the past
she was the assassin of hippolyta the
mother of wonder woman right just her
own assassin but the idea behind the
amazons as they were originally
introduced and how they were supposed to
function was protectors of the earth
right that at some point they would kind
of go out into the world and they would
protect it the amazons under the
direction of hippolyta abandoned that
mission and instead they remained
confined to themyscira
and just refused to leave and so marina
saw that as a betrayal of what their
original role was supposed to be and so
she ultimately ended up encountering
darkseid slept with him and then
produced a daughter who we know as grail
the idea behind this though was that she
knew
something like that was going to happen
like she knew that at some point
darkseid was going to arrive here and so
the whole idea behind this dark side war
taking place
between you know mobius and and darkseid
and these guys is that she knew that
darkseid would eventually show up on
earth somewhere along the line and
conquer it and so in order to ensure
that would never happen
she produced her daughter grail who in
turn she drove to ally herself or at
least raised her so that she would ally
herself with mobius and then in turn
try to kill darkseid or try to leave the
dark side's death and so scott free
picks up on this and says this is crazy
right this is a crazy thing you're
talking about
because in a war between somebody like
mobius and somebody like darkseid
billions of people on the world are
going to die and the response of marina
is you can't make an ammo without
breaking a few eggs right now of course
scot-free immediately rejects this
not because scot-free is a
tried-and-true hero his
morality is a little murky depending on
what circumstance we're talking about
what era of comics even that we're
reading
but he ultimately shoots this down
because in his mind the ends do not
justify the means
and so this of course leads to marina
black realizing he's gonna rat her out
right he's gonna try to find a way to
defeat her she in turn tries to kill him
he uses his mother box and he basically
teleports out now switching back to
superman and lex luthor there's a couple
things that go on here
the first is that once they're here and
they're on apocalypse superman does what
he can to tend to the wound of lex
luthor from his gunshot from his sister
the other thing is that once they
realize they're on apocalypse there's a
huge takeaway from this
right now we'll find out what that is
here in a second because while we're at
apocalypse we switch over to darkseid
and darkseid is informed that one
superman is here and that two
uh his daughter has summoned his
presence and so for the most part the
idea of darkseid is to focus on mobius
first that's really the biggest threat
and his biggest concern with regards to
superman he almost kind of lets on this
thing that nobody else really seems to
know where you have steppenwolf who's
kind of like i mean why don't we just
like why don't you just let me destroy
superman right why don't i go out there
and take care of him or the other guys
go out there and take care of him but
the response of dark side is
no superman is small beans at this point
in time i'm not worried about the
kryptonian here on apocalypse and so he
basically says tell the slaves who
exists out there on apocalypse that if
they're able to kill if one of them is
able to kill superman
they'll no longer have to work on
apocalypse they'll be spared any future
labor that they'll have to endure now
one thing to understand about the planet
of apocalypse
is it is a place of suffering and
torment that's true it's about as close
as you get to hell in dc
comics without actually going to hell
itself which of course is actually ruled
by lucifer morningstar
but there are people who dwell there
there are actual individuals there's a
society there right there's a society
you have different casts in that society
you have rebels who are working to fight
against darkseid you don't really hear a
lot about them
uh one because you don't really have any
comic books that focus exclusively on
that
and two the fact that dc doesn't really
focus on them is designed to kind of
point to the idea that darkseid rules
apocalypse with an iron fist
and no attempt by rebels is ever really
going to lead to their success in
toppling him right so it's almost like
dc's kind of saying
they're not important because they'll
never succeed anyway right so it's just
kind of
designed to go towards the idea that
darkseid's just kind of this
person who cannot be defeated by anybody
on his own on his own turf right on his
own planet and so following that
you have the justice league who jump in
you know kind of jump back into the fray
again
against grail and then of course mobius
basically makes his move kind of quells
the entire conflict
and is like we're done because when that
happens you have metron who shows up
here and metron's just kind of like this
has to end right kind of trying to
broker the piece again and saying this
has to end this has to stop
there's no way this is going to work now
of course he also kind of tells the
justice league you cannot defeat mobius
here right there's no way for you
to overcome the power he possesses
you're talking about a being capable
of wiping out all life on entire worlds
and like ending entire universes right
you're just
not on that level and so he ultimately
whisks them away to the rock of eternity
which as most of you guys probably know
is where the wizard shazam resides where
shazam billy batson
got his powers and the reason why
they're here is because the rock of
eternity is a place that for the most
part
cannot really be detected by people like
darkseid or mobius or something like
that it's like a black hole right just
you can't really get into it you can't
really get out of it unless you know the
proper means and so what you end up
having is wonder woman using your lasso
of truth on metron and then saying
how do we end this right how do we stop
this conflict how do we come out on top
you know is there any way for us to
defeat the anti-monitor and the only off
the only option that metron can answer
is you have to take the mobius chair
from me it's the only way to do it and
so she does exactly that with the lasso
of truth wrapped around him she yanks
metron off the mobius chair now
understand
it's not as though metron and his mobius
chair are like
attractive magnets right it's not like
magnets that are attracted through
polarization like it's just the super
impossible
thing to do not at all it can be done
quite easily uh if you have the the
proper level of power i mean if you or i
ran up on metron and try to take him off
the mobius chair that's not gonna happen
right but the lasso of truth is one of
these artifacts that transcends
normal levels of power and it just sort
of allows her to ensnare
almost anybody and force them to tell
the truth there are limits to it but
it's actually been used on the spectre
in dc comics now the the idea of it
being used on the spectre is largely due
to the fact that the spectres are so
incredibly powerful and and even then
he's just kind of bonded to a human host
so despite the power that he has it
affects more of the human side
than it does the godly side but we still
know that like it can affect
wildly powerful people but while she
does that ultimately you have
batman who dawns the mobius chair and
this is where you come across batman the
god of knowledge fills you guys who are
familiar with the concept but don't
really know where it originated from and
so right off the bat batman starts
asking a few questions to verify the
knowledge of the mobius chair right who
killed my parents
ping yes it's joe chill then he asked
the question what's the joker's true
name now
this is where the whole story of the
three jokers came from now keep in mind
this story was written back in like 2015
something along those lines 2014 2015
2016. so during that period it was about
four or five
years until we got an actual answer from
dc comics this right this moment right
here is the one that intrigued
everybody for so long like we need to
know like what the name of the joker is
you know and then later on you actually
end up learning that there's three
jokers that exist out there
and trying to find the names of those
three jokers but for its part with
batman being on the mobius chair
initially the justice league tries to
talk him down and says hey look like
this chair
is a level of power that we haven't
really messed with before and yes you're
capable batman but this is not something
you can just do on your own right i mean
because batman puts off all the
indication that he's becoming drunk with
power that he's almost being
influenced by the mobius chair there's
almost a kind of arrogance
that comes with the power that he
possesses but ultimately batman shoots
them all down and it's just like no
like i'm not getting off the mobius
chair this mobius chair belongs to me
right like i am the only person who can
really process all the knowledge that's
available or even use the mobius chair
adequately
and so the result is that there's no way
to get him off of that now the justice
league kind of resigns
and accepts this fact because there's
much bigger things to worry about than
whether or not batman's gonna get off
the mobius chair and if batman becomes a
threat later on then they'll in turn
respond and there is truth to the fact
that there's much bigger threats going
on
because there are when we switch back
over to superman and and lex luthor
as they're there on the planet of
apocalypse all these slaves just come
pouring on them right and attacking them
all as best they can the problem with
this
is that superman's x-ray vision is fuzzy
it's not really working the way that
it's supposed to and his initial thought
is that there must be some kind of lead
in the air that's designed to dilute his
powers because as we know
lead is the only only material that
superman cannot see through with his
x-ray vision and if there's lead in the
air
then it would mean that his x-ray vision
wouldn't be able to see clearly now of
course
lex luthor chimes in and says no like
there's you know there's cadmium and
there's polonium
and there's you know mercuric oxide but
there's very little lead in the
atmosphere and so it's kind of like okay
before they have a chance to figure out
what's going on
all these different slaves descend now
lex luthor and superman are
able to fight them off but in the
process superman is injured and that's
when lex luthor picks up on the fact
it's not anything like lead in the
atmosphere
that keeps superman from being able to
see properly with his x-ray vision
there's no sunlight here and because
there's no sunlight
superman's powers are draining and
that's the thing to understand about
superman's abilities he really
is a solar battery and so as long as you
keep that battery charged up you're
always going to be able to use it to its
full capacity the problem is that
once you take that battery off that
charger and then you just use that
battery's life up in its entirety
there's nothing left the battery's gonna
be dead and that's how that works so
it's like water in a cup
that as superman strays away the further
away he is or the longer he's away from
the yellow sun
the more he uses his powers the more
those powers begin to disappear
right so if he were to just use his
power sparingly he would still be pretty
effective but those powers are draining
every time he uses them and so you can
assume he's at something like you know
50 power or something along those lines
but picking back up with the justice
league once scot-free meets back up with
the team
and then in turn all of them are
teleported back to where grail and
mobius are at
that's when the arrival of darkseid
comes and the truth about this is that
despite the justice league's power their
desire to step in
and and bring this conflict to an end
there's really nothing they can do
there's absolutely nothing they can
offer in this this battle
all they can really do is like fight
against the forces of grail or the
forces of
of of you know mobius or something like
that but in terms of actually stopping
mobius and darkseid they're powerless
here right and that was really their
biggest fear was that while they're here
in seattle and while
all this stuff is popping off their
biggest fear was that the battle would
start to reach a tipping point where
there was nothing they could do to stop
it and so while you have mobius and dark
side facing off against each other on
apocalypse you have lex luthor doing
this final gambit where he looks at
superman and says okay
you are powered by solar energy these
solar pits here in apocalypse
they're solar fire right so i'm just
gonna throw you in it's the only thing
that i can think of so he literally
grabs superman
throws him in the pits of the of
apocalypse hoping that it'll basically
recharge his energies and bring him back
up
the problem with this is that when it
does he comes out completely corrupted
and twisted because the fire pits of
apocalypse have corrupting energy
they're designed to twist you out and to
mess you up and to cause all kinds of
problems they basically turn you into
your most evil self
and so kind of transitioning for a
second this is when we get the origin
more or less of
mobius right and this is where things
are completely were completely changed
recently with scott snyder's run on dark
nights metal death metal his justice
league run all that kind of stuff
so the the original origin or the actual
origin of mobius as it's given to us
in this particular story is that mobius
was at one point in time
a science guy right he was an explorer
he simply wanted to understand the
universe and how all those different
things work
and so he designed the mobius chair to
be this device that could basically
catalog all the information he'd gained
as he gained it because
the the mind was simply just unincapable
of handling
all that information the result of this
was that during his explorations he
ended up encountering the anti-life
equation
that if free will exists in the main dc
universe which is the ability for you to
choose your own path in life to make
your own decisions the right ones the
wrong ones all that kind of stuff and
the anti-matter universe because it's
the opposite of the main dc
universe it has to be the opposite thing
and so the opposite of free will
is anti-life the ability to have your
will dominated by others and so with
mobius discovering the anti-life he was
basically
bonded to the anti-life equation and
lived his life as essentially a
destroyer
the idea was that grail approached him
and effectively told him
if you kill darkseid you can free
yourself of the anti-life equation and
go back to being the person that you
were before
now of course again this has all been
changed that what scott snyder and all
those guys
did is basically established that in the
beginning there was simply perpetua the
creator of the multiverse and she was
the one who created the anti-monitor
and the monitor and the four drove
worlds and all that kind of new origin
right so the new origin as is told by
snyder is
the current origin for the anti-monitor
now how you wrap those two things
together how you can bridge that gap is
really up to you right it's really your
own way of doing this if if you even
choose to at all it's entirely possible
you can just ignore that right because
what snyder did was basically come back
and render the entirety of dark side war
as a thing that doesn't really matter
anymore right it's not really relevant
none of the none of the origin stuff
that was given here
is important anymore but the big
takeaway from this is kind of jumping
back to the battle between the
anti-monitor
and uh and dark side because the
anti-monitor is the living embodiment of
the anti-life equation
when darkseid commits his most desperate
act in summoning the black racer which
is an aspect of death and those the
black racer touch
basically end up dying being taken to
the afterlife that when he summons it in
the anti-monitor mobius
uses his power of the anti-life equation
to dominate the will of the black racer
and then in turn
bonds it to the flash barry allen
turning barry allen into the black racer
and so the black racer runs headlong
into dark side at the direction of
mobius and then
kills darkseid and darkseid effectively
dies right isca put
it's the end of the road for him but
like this is where we picked up this is
where we really ended last time
i think we did the tie-ins i'm not
entirely sure if we didn't let me know
um but i think we did all the tie-in
events because following this things pop
off right things go nuts because
now nobody knows what to do with dark
side being dead and in fact the gods
that give like shazam his powers for
example are all panicking
they're all bailing on right like
they're all basically bailing out it's
nuts right superman is like a twisted
corrupted
version of himself no one knows what to
do next there's nobody leading
apocalypse like it's probably the worst
case scenario for almost anybody
in the universe okay so picking up with
darkseid war act 2 which we never did
here on comics explain we
are currently joining with the aftermath
of darkseid dying and this is where
people are kind of panicking and people
don't really know what to do
right i mean darkseid kind of
represented this immutable
indestructible force that existed out
there in the multiverse and when his
with his death which was thought to be
impossible people are just kind of
shocked by it and so the first person to
really express the the concern over
what's happened
is the black racer is the flash and it's
one of these things where you would
expect the response of barry allen to be
somebody get this off of me right
somebody get this thing off of me i
don't want to be bonded to it i want to
be away from this you know i
value life i don't want to be bonded to
a being that
literally embodies death but instead you
know you kind of have this response by
mr miracle and saying that like once you
know the
aspect of death is bonded to a host it
cannot be undone
until death leaves that host or that
physical host dies or something along
those lines and the response of barry is
no you don't understand i want to
control this
right i don't want it i don't want to
get rid of it i want to control this
right so he is more or less being
corrupted
by this death entity that's taken over
him from there you switch over to
superman and lex luthor and again
superman's corrupted by the fact that he
was thrown in these solar pits and it
brings out every bit
of of anger and and wrath that he has
not in the sense that he's driven to
kill lex luthor but in the sense that he
kind of seizes him and says okay so like
here's what's going to happen right like
i know you want me to get you out of
this place you're not going anywhere
right you're staying here
because despite the efforts of lex
luthor to prove himself as being a good
guy
superman still still views him to be a
bad guy he still views him as being a
villain that he's simply just
biding his time until he commits some
campaign that's designed to allow him to
you know conquer metropolis or you know
kill superman or something along those
lines now the reality is that we as the
reader know
lex luthor legitimately is trying to be
a good guy like he legitimately is
trying to turn over a new leaf and the
funny thing is that this lack of trust
is not a one-off from dark side war in
fact when you pick up a dc rebirth and
you get into dan jurgens the adventures
of uh what is it superman and lois lane
or whatever it was called the one where
you kind of had like the pre-crisis
superman kind of hanging out with the
new 52 superman and the new 52 universe
then even then he doesn't trust lex
luthor but even then he sees him as you
know a guy who will always be a bad guy
so it's kind of interesting to see this
reformation of lex luthor but nobody
believing in him because it's one of
these things where you kind of feel bad
for his character it's like damn like
lex luthor's really trying to be a good
guy
and superman still won't give him any
slack but then you remember all the
stuff lex luthor's done
and then you're kind of like okay so
like superman has a legitimate reason to
be skeptical of this guy like lex
luther's always kind of been a dick
but ultimately superman just leaves him
there right he just kind of knocks him
knocks him to the side
and leaves him there and kind of gives
him this ultimatum if you come back to
earth i will tear you apart right i will
i'll kill you i'll crush you
just like i did with your armor and so
from there you switch over to batman and
two to hal jordan and this is where
things kind of got a little murky with
bruce wayne then hal jordan you know
where batman's like dark side's dead the
war is over it's time to go home
the response of hal is what about the
anti-monitor right and the response to
batman is he touched the anti-life
equation right that tournament into the
monster that he is now he's ejecting it
from his body and so when that's done
he's gonna go back to being who he was
before
let's just split right let's go our own
way and batman actually
intends to take the mobius chair back to
gotham and then use it as a means to
fight crime in gotham now here's the
problem with that right here's the
biggest issue with that izakana
stretches the limits of what batman
believes
as a superhero right whether you agree
with him or disagree with him the idea
behind batman
is it would be would be great to say one
step ahead
of what people intend to do but the the
problem with batman
with this mobius chair is most likely it
would corrupt him and push him to the
point that he would start getting
involved in pre-crime
given your habits given my intellect i
can deduce what crime or what you're
most likely going to do next so i'm
suddenly going to arrest you before that
happens now i am not necessarily opposed
to that not necessarily in the sense of
like arresting people before they commit
crimes but simply just having the mobius
chair and sitting down and saying what
have i been doing all this time
why am i letting superheroes go letting
super villains go free i should just
arrest these guys and throw them in jail
but you can't really
arrest a person for a crime they haven't
committed yet and so because of that it
would probably push batman to the point
that he might become a bit of a dictator
and depending on how he does it i may or
may not agree with it the waste being
depicted here would most likely be a
circumstance that i wouldn't necessarily
agree with and even hal jordan's just
kind of like you know that's
kind of a crazy thing but batman
ultimately sends him on his path and
says
like you have to go do your own thing
right you have to go to oahu because the
forces of the parademons are descending
on oh it's the single most powerful
place
in the entirety of the universe and the
pair demons have no leader anymore
there's no dark side and they are
inherently drawn to power so it's one of
these things where it's like go and do
your own thing now that of course
leads into the hal jordan uh dark side
war one shot right so the same thing
with barry allen figuring himself out
about the flash
uh you know the the black racer and so
on that leads into the barry allen into
the flash one shot and so from there you
pick back up with lex luthor who's
basically discovered by adora and she's
the leader of the forgotten people now
here's the thing about this
um i'm not aware that adora had ever
been featured in the new 52
or even really anything like post-crisis
um the only adora that i really know of
is like the old school character who was
like smitten for lex luthor basically
but she was somebody who existed back in
like the 60s and 70s right and she was
published back then so i'm not aware
that there's like any new version of
adora floating around out there and even
jeff
john seems to be kind of hand-wavy about
it in terms of how it's written you know
he's like well who you know lexi was
like who are you and she's like if you
knew if you knew of us then you know how
how impressive we are right so it's kind
of like uh they're people who exist
and that's basically it right that's
really the only explanation that we get
and in fact
the idea behind the forgotten people
seems to be they're just one of the
tribes that exist out there on
apocalypse that have somehow managed to
escape
the rule of pot of dark side or they
just kind of biding their time until
darkseid's death
and the latter seems to be the case
because she talks about a blind prophet
who basically writes that the night the
dark side dies that a human will appear
on apocalypse and that human would
change everything right it'd be the
greatest hero
from the world that they hail from from
a place called metropolis they would
have saved this world
multiple times they would be an orphan
they would be humbled by
by being the child of farmers they would
seek truth and embodiment of justice
she's describing superman
it's basically what she's describing
granted he's not really human but the
fact that he desires to be one of them
and they adopt him into their ranks he
might as well be
the other thing about this though and
that's what's kind of ironic is it could
also be lex luthor granted he's not
really the son of a farmer but
everything else that he's aspiring to
he's aspiring to become what superman is
whether he wants to admit it or not
that's what he's shooting for and so
when she asks the question are you this
man
his response is yes i am now the
indication here is he's kind of doing it
in a duplicitous way
where it's like uh yeah yeah of course
i'm the guy you're looking for
definitely
uh what do you need me to do you know
that kind of a thing you know that kind
of a uh
you know villainous sort of thing that
he's doing
but of course the the people around him
bow to him but adora does not and she's
like he hasn't earned that right yet and
so following that you pick
pick back up with billy batson who has
this kind of crisis now this goes into
the shazam
god of god storyline and it actually
left a lot hanging right in the sense
that there's this kind of
discussion going on among these gods
that power shazam some of them saying
like this boy will not be my power you
know some of them saying like he'll be
my vessel so
the gods are kind of fighting amongst
each other now this goes into
the old gods abandoning shazam and the
new gods taking its place
right but the one of the big issues and
we can we can remaster the one shot if
you guys want me to
one of the big issues that we ran into
with this is that there was a lot left
hanging
in the sense of what happened to these
various beings who possessed shazam
right because
after this you don't see shazam in dc
rebirth right you don't see him until
we got the newer issue that we did where
superboy prime came back that's all you
get we don't get anything between now
and then he's just
nowhere to be seen we have no idea
whatever happened to the to the guys
that empowered him or anything like that
and dc never really bothered to explain
it a lot of it was because it seemed to
be that their main focus was let's just
rebirth everything right let's just like
fix this whole new 52 initiative let's
make it what it's supposed to be
and that was the main focus everything
else kind of fell to the wayside what
you guys
saw with shazam between like the the end
of new 52
going into dc rebirth and everything
they came after dc's done that multiple
times that was the struggle of power
girl post
crisis after crisis on infinite earth
hawkman like all that kind of stuff it's
happened multiple times right stuff just
slipped through the cracks which i think
is really more a reflection of a lack of
organization than anything else but
while shazam essentially takes off
all you really have left are like cyborg
and you've got like
jessica cruz you know and like i said
you only really and you have wonder
woman you got like a couple people here
and of course this leads to the remnants
of the forces of darkseid
seizing onto them and kind of initiating
a great big huge fight now the the cool
thing to come out of this
is that picking back up with lex luthor
he's taken by the forgotten people
and and basically brought to this place
as kind of a great big huge power
harvester and the reason why is that
when darkseid died his omega sanction
the source of all of his power
left his body and came arriving back to
to the planet of apocalypse and the
reason why
seemed to be a kind of fail-safe that
when this happens that it'll stay there
until it's bonded to a new host whether
it's darkseid or somebody else and so
when the mega effect comes back because
lex luthor is hooked up to this whole
system
it'll bond to him and if he truly is the
person that the blind prophet's prophecy
foretold
then it'll bond to him successfully and
lex luthor will in effect
become the new dark side and so what you
end up doing is switching back over to
the
uh back over to earth with grail and
with uh marianna black
and while the two of them are talking we
end up learning that the the anti
monitor or mobius has put himself in a
kind of cocoon then he's wrapped himself
in this cocoon
for the purpose of getting himself
cleared up right of allowing him
to purge himself of the anti-life
equation and so where the bonding
process with lex luthor is successful
and lex luthor does become
what is in effect the new dark side the
fight between the forces of wonder woman
and cyborg and mr miracle and
the justice league that's left and the
forces of of like steppenwolf
and and those guys ends up coming into
full fray when you have them all just
sort of
battling each other and so when the
forces of wonder woman battle basically
the forces of of kanto and all those
guys you know the remnants
of apocalypse's elite fighting force the
the battle sort of
you know interrupted to a degree by the
arrival of big bartender now the reality
is that big barda and scot-free
are in effect on a honeymoon
following their marriage but no one's
supposed to know that they got married
right because
granny goodness the leader of the furies
if she found out she would come hunting
for
for big barta and scot-free and try to
kill them both and they would never
relent that's the thing to understand
they would never relent like they would
never ever back off
or anything like that they would always
come after them even if they were
defeated they would go back they would
regroup and they would come back again
and so scot-free and big varda would
spend their entire lives
essentially looking over their shoulders
and so where she comes in
big varda immediately kills kanto and
then in turn she turns to the rest of
the forces
that she kind of tells him look like
back off right you stay away we stay
away darkseid's dead
there's nobody giving you direction or
instruction anymore you're not being
lorded over
by any kind of of multiversal god demon
entity whatever or anything like that
just
go let us live in peace and the response
of lashina and all them is
no we are not going to you chose to
forego the
the black oath of the furies you
betrayed us and we will never forget
that betrayal we will
always come for you we will always come
back and get you and so following that
you kind of jump back to grail and
mariana black and the whole discussion
between the
between the two of them is the idea of
the anti-monitor purging himself of the
anti-life equation of mobius reverting
back to his previous form and that's
when you see this discussion that goes
on
where she kind of reveals that was the
whole intention behind it all that while
she's talking of course
superman arrives back on the scene and
immediately goes to attack steve trevor
right because it's kind of like you know
to a degree you're you're squeezing in
on my girl right because
superman and wonder woman were a thing
at one point in time but he kind of
shows back up on the scene and so while
all that's going on shazam's basically
gone out doing his own thing
flash is having this existential crisis
in relation to the black racer the
justice league is just kind of all over
the place right either they're
incapacitated they're hanging on by a
string or they're out
basically out and about having nothing
to do except deal with their own
personal crises that with the
with the anti-monitor finally purging
the anti-life equation from himself
grail takes it right and that's when we
realized this was all based on the idea
of her achieving the anti-life equation
that's what she was shooting for
this whole war was initiated by her even
her mom's campaign
was seeing the death of darkseid was
kind of modified and deviated by grail
herself
she instigated this entire conflict so
she could seize the anti-life equation
for herself and the reason why
the whole motivation behind this is she
felt like death was too good for
darkseid that she intended to basically
bond or at least does intend to find a
way to resurrect dark side and then bond
the anti-life equation to him and then
in turn
subjugate darkseid okay so i was
supposed to record this earlier but i
got sidetracked watching the megalodon
shark movie with jason statham
i love that movie that movie is amazing
so we are picking up with the
the batman one shot and i want to test
the waters here with the exception
of like shazam and green lantern to a
degree because it's referenced
not all the one shots are important but
they are optional they're just kind of
here for us to cover right now by the
time this video goes live
i will already be out of town for uh
valentine's day so i won't really know
whether or not you guys care about these
tie-ins until i get back
from from valentine's day weekend myself
and mariah are going out to get some
food and we're going to go hang out at
great wolf lodge in cincinnati we're
gonna have an amazing time so
uh this picks up kind of with batman
racing off to gotham to do his own thing
and the fact is he's actually kind of
been here
for a little while he's been here for a
few days and initially he meets up with
commissioner gordon now for those of you
guys who are gonna be reading
dc comics or who choose to jump into dc
comics
uh because of this video or any of the
other dark side war videos that i've
done
this took place during a branding
initiative called dcu
where there really was no continuity it
wasn't like you read batman comics you
read dark side war you read superman and
it all kind of fits into a time frame so
like you read one comic and then another
and then another instead it was just
kind of read whatever you want and so
the result is that if you go and you
read
the actual batman solo series at the
time commissioner gordon's batman but
when you read this commissioner gordon
is just
commissioner gordon it was really
frustrating for a lot of us who were
continuity hounds it was really sort of
driving us insane but for the average
person i think it was moderately
successful all in all they ended up
canceling it because i think
most everybody hated it but the
important thing here is that
commissioner gordon is getting kind of
pissy and the reason why is because what
batman's been doing in the city of
gotham
is he's basically just been leading to a
series of events whereby
criminals who were handed over to the
police department have to be released
and the reason why is because of what we
talked about in the dark side war video
where batman is basically processing
pre-crime right which is to say batman
is looking at what people's intentions
are using the mobius chair
and then essentially snatching them up
and handing them over to the cops before
they actually do anything the reality
is that the justice system cannot arrest
you for something that it thinks you
might do
if there's no tangible evidence to link
you to that particular action
right so i mean you could have all kinds
of stuff in your car
and there's no real way for them to link
you to the crime now there are laws that
kind of deal with that for example like
if you're in possession of any kind of
drug paraphernalia and you've got it
wrapped up so say for example you have
like a pound of weed and then you've got
it packaged in like one ounce baggies
just for yourself they can arrest you
for possession with intent to distribute
right because you could
potentially distribute it it's kind of a
nonsense law and there's no reason weed
should be illegal in the first place but
that's just kind of the nature of how
some of those laws work but for batman's
case
he's handing people over who he's used
the mobius chair to determine
are going to be doing things like
robbing people uh murdering other people
things like that but because the nature
of laws is that they're designed to be
reactionary which is to say
we stop you or we we arrest you after
you've done a thing
as opposed to being something that
happens before you do a thing there's
nothing that the justice department can
really do right there's nothing that
like
you know that the police can actually do
here so they just gotta let all these
guys go and it's kind of irritating uh
commissioner gordon to a degree but more
so than that is batman
because ever since batman got on the
mobius chair
he's become very kind of you know ha ha
i know everything
and to a degree he was always kind of
that way he was always kind of like you
know if you can keep up with me then
it's just
you know thank god for small favors you
know it was always that kind of thing
but he was never really one of those
where he just seems
so disconnected from everything going on
right and that's really how he seems in
the mobius chair he just seems so
incredibly disconnected and he almost
kind of talks about the chair as if it's
a thing that he has to have
and he even refers to people as the
sense that like there's just a baseline
nature to all human beings that cannot
be altered based instincts there are
people out there that have a base
instinct kill
a base instinct to rob that kind of a
thing it's almost batman to the small
degree that he did
favor the possibility of people being
redeemed has even even really just lost
that it's just kind of like people do
bad things
and i'm just catching them before they
do it's a very cynical perspective but
here's the funny thing about this
the way the batman handles a lot of
these situations are actually
awesome so here's one instance right
there's these guys who are going to be
heading to this place
called the alpha club and they're well
they intend they tend to rob the place
ultimately they got a whole bunch of
guns so you know most likely somebody
was going to get shot but batman
basically uses the mobius chair
and then teleports them to the southern
tip of the arctic circle and is like
you're about 50 miles away from a
research station here uh just be aware
you are surrounded by mountains not the
biggest deal doesn't usually get down to
negative 40 but it is currently negative
two so uh if you start burning the
different things in your car
using the gunpowder and your your
bullets then you can probably keep
yourself warm there's a ship that's on
its way here uh because it's just kind
of making its way
through the ice they don't know you're
here but you know you guys will stumble
upon each other and maybe they'll find a
way to save you but
uh while you're while you're waiting on
them to arrive praying to god that you
actually live
you can think about your actions and
just leaves
[Laughter]
just leaves he's just like bye and then
just you know okay bye bye and then just
just takes off and that's he just leaves
him there following that he goes to
another place where there's a guy named
mr phillips but he actually breaks into
his ex-wife's apartment with a knife in
hand
essentially drunk and the whole thing is
that he's pissed off because after
everything he'd done his wife had
basically left him and divorced him uh
the reality is that he was beating her
and so it's not as though she left him
because he was down on his luck because
he was running into some problems in the
job and she's like you're no measurement
at all you know and then just took off
to
to find greener pastures it's because he
was beaten on her right so batman ends
up snatching this guy up and then takes
him to themyscira now initially the
the women on the skier the amazons are
just like you're not supposed to be here
you can't just come here
whenever you want you can't just walk
into this place and they're like who who
is this guy and he's like well this
guy's name is mr phillips and he likes
to beat his women and he intended to
murder his ex-wife with with the knife
that he has in his hand
before i intervened uh and so i have no
intention of leading him here but i felt
like spending a little while here will
help
change his view on women and they're
like yeah yeah it will
so you know the theme of scares are
going to help him come to understand his
place in the bigger picture but that's
kind of what happens here now
batman in turn makes things personal
right he makes things very very personal
here
and what he does is he goes to crime
alley and notice this being the god of
knowledge having all this this knowledge
at his fingertips knowing everything
that's going on
across the universe batman could deal
with all the universe's problems instead
he really just kind of reduces down to
dealing with his own because he's
exactly what we've always said he was
he's a sad little boy crying because his
mommy and daddy got shot
now it doesn't make him any less of a
person because of that that's just the
core nature of batman their deaths at
the hands of joe chill and so what he
does is he actually teleports directly
to where joe chill's at and gotham state
penitentiary now
joe chill is not really serving a life
sentence he was serving his sentence but
he always keeps getting shot down by the
parole board so he is more or less
serving a life sentence and he always
will because he essentially murder
people who are rich and powerful and as
we know
it usually carries a heavier sentence
when you when you murder those
individuals who have money and are
influential
and so the results of this is that the
the conversation bruce has
with joe chill is one of wrath and
vengeance right and that that's that's
how we kind of know
the mobius chairs corrupting him because
when you look at batman
whenever he's dealing with situations
like this especially when he's usually
dealing with criminals the element of
using fear is only done
insofar as to throw them off guard or to
use it as
a way to kind of terrify them out of
their actions or something along those
lines right it's designed to be
something that that sort of messes with
people's heads right it's mind games
shadow games that kind of thing he never
really uses fear for the actual purpose
of just
terrorizing a person right just personal
vengeance he never really uses it for
that way but that's what he's doing with
joe chill
he's absolutely terrorizing this guy now
some could say and you really could
argue he's got a right to do this but
the crazy thing
is is that he actually teleports him
directly to uh to crime alley to the
point to the the place where the crime
was committed and joe chill almost kind
of gets excited about what was going on
he's like yeah man you know i killed
gotham's movies and shakers and that's
why i keep serving a life sentence you
know i
you know i i put a bullet in these two
super rich people
he's like in that moment i was the most
powerful i ever was i had the power of
life and death
i decide who lives and who dies you know
and then he starts talking about bruce
wayne he's like you know i bet that
little kid he had nightmares and
everything you know he was
i was that little kid's boogeyman right
this whole idea that he felt like god
but he felt like god insofar as he could
snuff out the lives of others or
determine or decide that they could live
and then became like this specter that
just haunted the life of the
eight-year-old boy who survived and one
of the things that he talks about here
is that when when batman
says like you know give me a number like
i know the waynes weren't the first ones
i know they weren't the only ones that
that you killed
give me a number he says 40 that he's
killed 40 people because of the fact
that it made him feel more empowered now
he did this at the request of others
he did it of his own volition but
regardless it satisfied a personal
desire
for him and that's the crazy thing is
because when bruce reduces it down and
says i'm not really here for the 38
other people that you killed i don't
really care about them i care about the
two people you cured killed here that
night in crime alley the response to joe
chill is why
like why do you care about the two
people that i killed here in crime alley
why would batman be concerned about that
and that's when bruce reveals his
identity and says because i'm bruce
wayne right like and that immediately
scares the hell out of joe chill right
absolutely scares the heck out of him
because he's like i'm all grown up right
the first words that you have when you
when you come back to this place is
you wish you would kill the little kid
who was there so that nobody would have
been able to trace you to the crime and
you would have gotten away scot-free
that's the first thing you do
but like i'm your boogeyman now you have
to accept the fact that now
you're the one who created the batman
i'm here because of you i'm here because
you killed my parents
and so i can make your life a nightmare
in this place joe chill i can let word
reach the ears of all the prisoners
around here who were here
because of batman that you're the reason
he exists if everybody here finds out
you're the one who created batman by
committing a murder in crime alley
they're all going to come for you
they can't get to me batman but they can
get to you right so if they can't kill
me they'll do the next best thing and
they'll make your life a living hell in
every conceivable way and in some ways
that you can't even imagine
so i just want you to know right that's
that's literally the whole thing he
wants joe till to know the fact that joe
chill created batman
joe chill is the reason that batman
exists it's all about just
intimidation and it's all it's all about
just terrorizing this guy and of course
he also goes on to say like you will
never tell anybody who i am
you will never give anybody my identity
if you will i will make sure that
you die in this place and that's really
what would happen like batman if batman
told people
that joe chill created batman they would
kill joe chill and so in a roundabout
way maybe not so many
not in so many words batman's like i
will have you killed in this place
that's basically what he's saying now of
course
once he gets back directly to uh to the
the bat cave and you have alfred there
waiting on you know with drinks and that
kind of a thing and dinner to kind of
help him get together
batman start is basically bleeding from
the ears and the nose and the mouth and
the reason why is because the chair
is one of these things where it doesn't
necessarily have a mind of its own
but processing all that information kind
of creates a bond or a link
between the person and the chair and so
if you start using the mobius chair for
the for means that it wasn't meant to be
used for personal gratification
different things like that essentially
defying the will of the chair
then it'll in turn cause problems now
the other thing this kind of hit out
here
is that there almost seems to be a
parasitic relationship here in the sense
that if it was symbiotic
batman gains something to chair gain
something and then they just both kind
of go forward but batman's struggling
the way that he is bleeding the way that
he is he goes as far as to say that he's
sustained by the chair right the chair
feeds it basically keeps him
uh nourished he doesn't have any need
for food or water or anything along
those lines that it does satisfy a need
of the chair in that way
but it's taking a toll on bruce wayne
it's killing it in effect right
because while bruce wayne may very well
be sustained the chair itself
almost seems to be sucking the life out
of him and that's that seems to be one
of the reasons why only new gods only
somebody like metron
or a person like that who has who is why
all standards of measurement
uh immortal in comparison to whatever
means of destruction are available out
there right he's not
truly indestructible he can be killed
but it's very very difficult to do
but because you have to have a kind of
physiology to be able to withstand the
rigors of the chair that it wasn't
really meant for mortal men and so
because of that it's taking the toll on
batman now alfred really kind of asked
him like why don't you just leave the
chair the sponsor bruce is well i can
leave it any time i want to
notice this it's almost like a drug or
like an addiction of some kind right
bruce believes he has to have the chair
he needs the chair and so there's almost
kind of a mental link in that way
he talks like an addict well i can quit
anytime i want i can quit drugs anytime
i want i can stop drinking anytime i
want
i can quit gambling anytime i want i got
10 to 1 odds i can stop tomorrow you
know it's that kind of a thing but
ultimately he just doesn't acquiesce he
just
stays on the chair now there almost
seems to be a kind of physical link in
the sense of batman cannot
actually get up the chair is keeping in
there but we don't really get enough
information to know whether
or not that's the case it just kind of
seems to me he tries to stand up and he
can't really do it almost as if he
he is attempting to get himself out of
the chair but doesn't actually want to
leave right maybe
you know not faking it or anything like
that but it's just a desire to stay in
the chair
and to maintain all that information and
so ultimately he says like
me being in this chair is really what's
best for gotham me having this at my
disposal this is the best thing for us
because now i can do a better job of one
keeping gotham under control but two
i can focus on the one thing that has
plagued me ever since i became batman
the one guy that i've never been able to
figure out the person whose
entire existence is as much an enigma to
me as it is
seemingly everybody else his whole focal
point now that he has this knowledge
with regards to the mobius chair
is to figure out a way to understand who
the joker is
where he came from and what his whole
story is about now for those of you guys
who want to continue off
from where this whole idea about the
jokers continues we have
the story the three jokers down in the
description you can watch that because
that'll actually pick up
immediately after this not directly and
you know it wasn't really written until
about five years after the story was
published but in terms of chronology and
in terms of fitting into what's going on
with batman right now
it fits in later what's going on guys
this is rob and we are picking back up
again
with uh dark side war and in this
instance we're covering the
shazam one shot when billy batson gets a
new pantheon of gods now
here's a crazy thing about this right
this was probably one of the most
anticipated and exciting things to come
out of dark side war and for those of
you guys who are new to comic books this
is usually how it works right if you
guys are familiar with comics that's
awesome bear with me here for a minute
while we kind of get people who are not
really familiar with comics caught up
so usually when it comes to a particular
character or team more often than not
uh publishers or at least it used to be
this way publishers would use
like big landmark events as a way to
kind of reshuffle and change things
more recently it just kind of changes
based on any one new particular writer
right they just kind of introduce a
story arc shift things up and then
some kind of change gets made that just
gets carried on from that point going
forward
with dark side war this is one of the
instances when dc was just kind of like
let's change things up for shazam right
let's shift things around and let's
let's introduce like a new pantheon of
gods right now
is as it is a good time as any and so
what we ended up getting was that during
the main dark side war event
following the death of darkseid there
was this kind of ripple effect that was
sent throughout
essentially the the realm of the gods
and the results of this is that billy
batson lost his connection to the old
gods mercury
and and zeus and and so on and so forth
you know solomon and whatnot
and he was replaced or really was
replaced with a with a new god and even
then
even inside of this is called the six
gods of antiquity antique gods that's
kind of what they're referred to as now
when this happens
there's this kind of huge influx of all
these different voices that come pouring
into his head
because for the most part they're as new
to this as he is right they're not
really sure why they're bound to him and
he's not really sure where these new
gods came
from it's suddenly just this huge influx
of voices from all these various beings
he's discovering new powers the ability
to manipulate what's called the living
fire
as opposed to simply just being the the
living lightning in a traditional sense
and so it leads to them kind of goading
him on and almost kind of just being
like you know shout the word right you
know say shazam different things like
that
and ultimately he initially does but
then suddenly he's whisked away
basically to the source now the way that
dc explains this
is that gods in dc comics never actually
die
instead they're basically taken to the
source now the important thing to
understand here this is
kind of a jack kirby thing but kind of
not uh the reason why i say that is is
back in the 70s when jack kirby left
marvel and then went to dc comics he had
his whole fourth world right the idea of
jack kirby doing that he kind of
sidetracked from this for a second
the idea of jack kirby introducing like
darkseid and all those guys in the old
the old
fourth world comics was to create like a
holy separate publication
that didn't really have anything to do
with the mainline dc comics kind of what
you see now with like vertigo right it's
like lucifer and like the specter things
like that
spectre crosses over more often than not
but you've never really seen a story
where like
superman and wonder woman in the justice
league have to like align themselves
with lucifer morningstar to face off
against some kind of threat uh but the
idea with the fourth world was to make
it wholly separate and unique and the
source was a part of that and all that
kind of good stuff the whole thing
behind this is
that following him leaving dc all the
fourth world stuff was rolled over into
the main dc universe which is why you
have dark side it's part of like the the
new 52 or you had dark side
even before that he would face off
against superman and things along those
lines but the idea of god's dying and
going to the source was a concept that
jack kirby had thought of
but not one that was routinely used and
in fact it really wouldn't be until neil
gaiman's eternals in marvel comics that
that concept by jack kirby was actually
used more prominently when you figured
out that's where the celestials go that
when celestials and marvel comics die
they go to a kind of afterlife for the
celestials they rejoin quote unquote
marvel's version of the source that's
kind of rolled over here right so it's
one of those things where
it was kind of created by dc but not
really never never really used that it
was used by marvel then it was used by
dc but
it all really kind of roots back to jack
kirby which is why he's considered to be
one of the most landmark people out
there but what dc basically establishes
here is that the old gods that shazam
was previously tied to
are not really dead they simply just
rejoin the source and at some point
along the line it basically opens the
door for them to return
in some form or fashion so like solomon
hercules atlas zeus achilles mercury
they're not really tied to uh to shazam
anymore instead he's got a whole new
pantheon but the crazy thing about this
is that when steve orlando wrote this it
was designed to kind of
springboard into a new series of shazam
stories and a lot of that was because
shazam's comics is as interesting as he
was and as hardcore as his fan following
is
even they would have to admit the
biggest problem with billy batson is the
story's run stagnant that they don't
really
do a lot with his character he's there
but the last time he really had anything
great was during the early 90s when you
learned that like when he turns into
shazam he turns into what he remembers
his father looking like or what he what
he imagines his father to look like or
something along those lines
like that's it right there really
haven't been a lot of meaningful moments
behind billy batson and so this was kind
of designed to say okay well let's just
get rid of his old gods replace them
with new gods
and then go from there and so what we're
basically told is that in this interim
moment like this this split moment of a
second between the time that that dark
side died
and the time that billy was given these
new these new abilities that
time was kind of frozen to a degree that
it works differently when it comes to
gods but the idea is the old gods were
removed the new guys were put in but it
was an incomplete process
that the wizard shazam was the one who
started it but before the transition
could be completed that a villain named
zonus had basically struck and he was
kind of going through the process
of essentially eliminating or taking
over all these old gods and then kind of
empowering himself and what we're
basically told
is that before darkseid or any of those
guys there was just like this this kind
of butcher right this this primal
inspiration for suffering right he's
basically given to us as like the
original incarnation of evil now again
this is not really designed to stand
alongside vertigo it's designed to stand
kind of alone from vertigo right so
that's why you don't really see any
correlation here with regards to how
this guy zone is
compares to like lucifer morningstar or
something like that just no real there's
dc doesn't just doesn't really cross
those things over too much but the idea
is that shazam having this new level of
power would basically put him in a
position to overpower zonus right to
kind of confine him back to where he's
supposed to be
and so in the midst of that conversation
when he's talking to this woman uh
annapelle
you know as part of his new pantheon
suddenly he's yanked away and he ends up
coming into
uh this guy who basically refers to
himself as siva the dancer of
destruction and each one of these
instances each one of these gods that he
comes across with kind of gives them a
little
a little more of a piece of the puzzle
right that in the sense that where zone
is kind of gone in this campaign of
cruelty and whatnot that ultimately he
was defeated
right and when he was defeated his
cruelty was replaced with his son's
cruelty that his son became you know
equally cruel to him
and so the result of this is that when
he's met with these new powers they kind
of question him whether or not he could
actually use these powers effectively
whether he could channel these abilities
in the right way
to actually defeat zonus like does this
kid have the power to pull that off but
before he's really able to provide any
credible evidence to the fact that he
can do this outside of
you know don't question what it is that
i'm capable of if that's if you guys
really see me as just some common mortal
then none of you really understand what
i'm about then suddenly he's yanked away
and then he's brought to the presence of
a woman by the name of ate who's the
goddess of
impulse and the way she kind of explains
herself here is really intriguing she
really establishes the idea that where
the other people lend him particular
abilities
she lends him a concept right she lends
him the idea of being
impulsive and this could be looked at as
a bad thing but not necessarily and the
reason why
is because whenever two foes go into
conflict with each other there's this
kind of expectation
in terms of how things will play out
right in the sense that zonus kind of
being this ancient evil that is
basically returned would look at billy
batson in a lot of ways underestimate
him right or at the very least say okay
if you're empowered by these gods that
i'm familiar with then knowing those
gods as i do
i would expect you to act something in
the same fashion because
why else would they give you their
powers and even then he would look at
him as somebody just being an earthling
and say okay as a person from earth i
can expect you to act like most
earthlings
impulsiveness kind of grants this sort
of distraction right this idea that you
know it kind of throws them off guard
like well what is he going to do next
that kind of a thing
acting in an impulsive manner and even
then it's kind of expanded to a degree
right the idea that you know this
this offering that she brings him could
be something that could distract him
from the beating he's going to get now
she's not really saying that insofar as
something being beneficial she's kind of
staying from the perspective of like
you're probably gonna get wrecked
right so not really having a whole lot
of faith in him but again before he's
able to kind of explain it to her before
he's able to offer
any real indication of what it is that
he's about he suddenly yanked away again
and he's almost brought to to this guy
who looks very similar to what we would
expect from like
certain or even like hephaestus from
greek mythology now he calls himself
ron muir which he kind of says like
there is nobody else out there like me
now the truth about this is he grants
him what's called the living fire which
is more or less something akin to the
living lightning
we didn't really we don't really know
the full effect of what his fire can do
the full-on like level of durability and
and
you know how it compares to something
like hellfire or something along those
lines because of course
he's yanked away and then suddenly he's
brought before the wizard shazam who's
facing off against
zonus that with zona's being free that
now he's going through and trying to
take out each one of these individual
gods now when he shows up here
billy of course watches the wizard get
into this conflict and then zones
reveals his true nature
in saying that he's basically yuga khan
right the sire of evil that he's the
actual father of dark side now this is
not the first time
that we've seen yuga khan in dc comics
he existed long before this but you know
the last time we'd previously seen him
he was locked away in the source wall so
presumably
he had managed to find some way to
escape now the fact that he's here is
one of these things where it's kind of
like he intends to use his power
combined with the powers of the other
gods presumably through billy batson to
basically raise the world and kind of
sees his son as a failure right the idea
that like he's picking up where darkseid
left off
that dark side was just not strong
enough to be able to overtake the world
he wasn't strong enough to be able to
overtake earth's superheroes but that
yuga khan himself
can now the idea behind this was to kind
of again springboard into like
new stories that could be told coming in
the aftermath of dark side war and
initially like he just kind of takes off
right headed towards earth now billy
batson of course
transforms into the wizard shazam and
brandishing the power of these new gods
that he possesses goes toe-to-toe
with yuga khan and is able to actually
overpower him
just by the the strength speed
durability all that kind of stuff he's
able to overpower him even when you have
yuka khan who's playing mind games and
saying like nothing you do can stop me
and i will take your friends and i will
put them in the kilns and you will watch
them burn and you will smell them as
they die
like just all these these horrible
things that he's putting inside of his
head at the end of the day
none of it matters and he's still able
to present himself as the earth's
mightiest mortal now
that's the point that billy was trying
to get across to all these new gods who
questioned whether or not he would have
the ability to overcome somebody like
yuga khan and saying
that the beauty of humanity is that
we're not inherently limited
that a lot of races out there or a lot
of beings out there may be confined to
this kind of world view or this view of
their existence or something like that
and
in that limitation they quite literally
cannot think outside the box
but humans are driven and powered by
their imagination
and the things that come with it and so
because that billy doesn't really see
any limits to his power and it's one of
these rare instances when you see him
almost
kind of like a level of power that
seemingly has no real limit now the
reason why i say that is because there
are big differences between the powers
that billy had before and the powers he
has now a lot of them are still the same
having like super strength and like
super speed and things like that right
the lightning of mammorag and that's
that's not really a huge difference in
what we saw before but
having this kind of boldness that comes
from eight right the ability to
manipulate the power of the source which
came from
zones having the ability to manipulate
the fires of ranmir this was all brand
new stuff but no matter how you slice it
the result is that he overpowers yuga
khan
and then essentially knocks him out and
so when that happens we have a couple
things that happen the first
is that we learn the actual name of the
wizard shazam who says his name's
mamaragan right so this is kind of a big
reveal when it first happened and that
man moragan was basically the fifth god
that billy was getting his powers from
the sixth source of his power came from
yuba khan himself but the important
takeaway from all this
is that billy basically had a new source
of power that he could use in stories
going forward the downside of this is
we never really saw anything come of it
right because dark side war ended and
then
dc comics almost immediately picked up
with the events of rebirth and just kind
of
blew all this off right so dark side war
was just kind of ignored
seemingly across the board outside of
reference to the fact that it happened
we didn't really see
anything from billy batson outside of
him showing up in like a constantine
comic
maybe some wonder woman stories but
nothing of any real significance to give
us this idea that like steve orlando's
vision
of catapulting into like a new era of
storytelling focusing on shazam with a
whole new level of power
we never got to see that right which is
really disappointing when you think
about it because
it was a way to just breathe fresh life
into a character who for quite some time
has seemingly just kind of become
stagnant
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with dark side war this time we're
covering the flash one shot the flash
tie into everything that's going on now
keep in mind
these tie-ins take place between the
ending of act two and the beginning of
act three but one thing that i want to
draw your attention to is a question
that i got from a lot of you guys in the
comments section
who were asking how it is that like the
black racer slash the black flash
because they're basically the same thing
how those characters relate to like
death of the endless versus necron and
different things like that because any
guy
anybody who's been reading dc comics for
quite some time knows that there's all
these different versions of
death right necrons like death for the
green lanterns and
like the black racer slash the black
flash is death for the new gods and the
flashes and so on and so forth
so here's the important thing to
understand here in dc comics you only
really have
one absolute representation of death and
that's death of the endless that's
really all it is
everybody else is really more akin to
like cheron right the fairy man from
greek mythology who would take people
across the river styx
that's really all they are in in some
form or fashion right necron is almost
kind of like this being that sort of
stands in this
kind of purgatory-like place um and
those individuals who
basically die kind of pass through his
realm which sits as what most people
refer to as a temporary way station
until they actually go to the realm of
death of the endless where they
live their eternal life and whatever
afterlife awaits them
uh the black racer the black flash
functions more or less the exact same
way
the black racer aspect is what takes the
new gods from their existence to the
realm of death
and the black flash does the exact same
thing but for speedsters
the difference is that when speedsters
die they join the speed force right
that's kind of their afterlife
um now a lot of this really came by way
of action comics number 894
which was the aftermath to blackest
night and there's a point where lex
luthor
actually encounters death of the endless
and asks the question about blackest
night right like was that you were you
the reason why people were coming back
from the dead and the answer that death
gives
is not necessarily a direct one like no
i didn't do that here's how it happened
that's not really the answer that we get
instead it's just kind of like yeah i
saw all that go on and it seemed like
everybody was having a lot of fun
people do escape the realm of death i am
pretty busy and so what that really
pointed to is the idea that necron is
not a representation
of death of the endless as far as as it
pertains to the green lanterns necron is
a wholly different entity of his own
court
and that he was basically able to bring
people from the realm of the dead into
the realm of the living
hence the blackest night event so it's
not as though all these different
avatars are just
aspects of death they're just beings
that are out there and this is really
shown by the level of power they have
necron can be defeated the black racer
the black flash they can be defeated
death of the endless cannot be defeated
if death of the endless were to show up
and face off against the justice league
they would all die like
she represents a concept in ideology and
so the only way the death of the endless
could truly perish
is if all things simply just cease to
exist so having said that this basically
picks up with barry allen once he's
bonded to the black racer and the
revelation
that he had basically killed darkseid
while he was imbued to the black racer
using the anti-life equation as it was
controlled by mobius and one of the
things this kind of hit on here
is sort of a repeat of what we had
previously seen in the sense that he
doesn't really want to be separated from
the black racer or the black flash that
he wants to control it but this is kind
of like an internal struggle because
it's not as though barry's operating of
his own accord
and in fact he manages to seize control
if only for a moment and then breaks
away from the black racer right
literally manages to separate himself
and then he just runs as fast as he
possibly can
uh that that he can basically outrun
death now this is the second time we've
seen this the first time we saw it we
didn't necessarily see it happen
it wasn't really until you got to like
flash rebirth in the aftermath of final
crisis that we actually found out what
was going on right in the original
crisis on infinite nurse event barry
allen was believed to have been dead
which
paved the way for wally west to become
the new flash over the course of
the entirety of the 90s and the mid to
late 2000s but when barry allen came
back in 2009 with final crisis
and then that was followed up with flash
rebirth by jeff johns it basically gave
us this this depiction or kind of
established to us
that following the events of crisis on
infinite earth that barry allen had just
been outrunning death all this time and
that during the events of final crisis
he was able to literally escape the the
speed force
and basically get away from death and so
because of that very outrunning death
this is not a new concept but it's also
a little bit different here because of
the fact that there's a there's almost
kind of understanding between the two of
them in the sense that it's one of these
things where death sort of plays these
games and says like or at least
the black racer plays these games and
says if if darkseid himself could not
conquer me
what chance do you think you have and
even kind of makes these things of like
death is precious to you death created
you
right death created you when it took her
right when it took your mom nora allen
now of course we know that eobard thon
killed nora allen but
death was kind of like the follow-up
right like she died and then she was
whisked away by death but it's one of
these things where notice
that uh the black racer doesn't really
say me he doesn't say like you know when
i took her right i am precious to you i
created you that's not really what
what's being said here it's death did
this
right so whisking barry allen off to the
realm of death is more or less what what
this whole thing is but
in that moment he has this kind of of he
kind of gets this back and forth and he
actually ends up
not really coming to terms with the
black racer but kind of having this bit
of a conversation with the black racer
and this is a really cool moment here
right because what ends up happening is
the black racer basically says
like this is central city right when
they kind of stop for a minute he says
like this is central city right this is
the home of the flash that which
the flash fought and protected for eons
right 2.5 million people live here now
one of the things that the black racer
says is like i am what you need to learn
if life is to continue now look at the
streets that you would protect
this is an important thing here because
barry allen has largely just
ran away from death that's the story of
barry allen there is truth to the
statement that death created barry there
is an absolute truth there that in the
aftermath of barry allen's mom dying
that that her death and the concept of
death have basically dominated his life
right the entire flashpoint event was
based on him trying to go back in time
and save his mom's life and keep her
from dying which he succeeded in doing
and then turn the whole world upside
down in an alternate timeline but like
christ is on infinite earth outrunning
death for 20 years until he managed to
come back
constantly trying to get away from death
just refusing to die
and it's one of these things where it's
like this has to happen right like death
has to exist
and death has to have a host and black
racer kind of races off you know just
kind of takes off and it's like i'm
going to kill everybody and it's like
you know can barry allen possibly stop
this from happening and as barry does
this and as barry chases down this black
racer and bears witness to all these
various people who are dying
barry comes to the realization that this
has to happen that if death does not
have a host that death would just
run rampant there'd be nobody to curtail
death there'd be nobody
to reel it in nobody to keep it kind of
chained and occurring
and operating the way it's supposed to
now there's precedence for this we saw
that with hal jordan when he was bonded
to the specter right in the aftermath of
like emerald twilight and all that kind
of stuff that hal jordan became the new
host for the spectre and then eventually
they were separated and the spectre had
no hosts and so the spectre went on a
war path right the representation of
god's vengeance just went on this
absolute war path and so the idea is
that if black racer functions more or
less the same way even if it's only a
concept or something akin to the idea of
death if there's no one there to chain
it it would just run rampant because
all it does is kill people and so
there'd be no discerning factor there
there'd be no instance of like you know
this guy's 26 years old in the prime of
his life there's nothing wrong with him
he didn't walk in front of a vehicle or
anything like that it's not his time and
death would just
snatch him up because death just kills
right and it would kill indiscriminately
and so because of that it's one of these
things where barry basically realizes
that the only way
for this to work right the only way for
him to successfully bond
to to the black racer is for him to take
a life to kind of
cement the relationship between the two
that with barry allen
taking a life using the scythe of the
black racer that in turn it would make
him
into the new black racer right he would
basically become the new living
embodiment for
the black flash black racer what have
you and so he actually ends up going
directly to iris west
now it's not really done with the
intention of killing iris west that's
not his goal here the reason why he ran
to iris west and is something that she
begins to pick up on when he basically
brands the
scythe and transforms into the black
flash is she realizes you came here
because you know i'm the only one that
can stop
you right i'm the only one that can keep
you from doing this i'm the only one
that can pull you back from the brink
if this was anybody else if it was
anybody else out there in the world you
would have struck them down with a
scythe and it would have been the end of
them they would have died and you would
officially become the black racer but
even if only on a subconscious level
you knew that i could pull you back you
couldn't bring yourself to kill me and
so in that moment the idea of barry
being taken over by the black
black racer is temporarily halted and
the black racer even in an effort to
kind of tempt barry allen
jumps like kind of manifest in different
forms then like in turn what would
happen you know maybe i should just
see what would happen if gorilla grodd
had my power what kind of pandemonium
and chaos that he could bring to this
place and so barry kind of says okay
fine so just one life all i have to do
is take one life
and then it'll cement us and and the
black racer is like yes and he's like
okay you got it i'm gonna kill you
and immediately chases after the black
racer right now when this happens a
black racer's like what
that's not how this is supposed to be
right that's not how this is supposed to
work and and like immediately just goes
fleeing right so like the shoe is
totally on the other foot and it's like
begging barry allen to stop now
ultimately barry allen drawing the
scythe back
does manage to kill the black racer
right he kills the black flash the
problem with this
is that as soon as that happens he's
almost kind of greeted with like this
sort of depiction of his mom with this
kind of you know
afterlife s concept but when he kills
the black racer
like the black racer as an ideology
right the the kind of representation of
death
is just totally unhinged right it's
completely and totally released
death is 100 free for the first time now
remember this is kind of a this is kind
of dc playing it fast and loose right dc
saying
the black racer kind of is or maybe it's
not a version of death
so you can just kind of take it for what
it's worth but what it basically means
is it's almost a repeat of what we saw
with like the specter and hal jordan
that because there's nobody anchoring it
there barry allen realizes
death has to have a host death has to be
has to be bonded to someone that if it's
not bonded to anybody
because darkseid's no longer alive to
control death death would just
run unfettered across all of existence
and just kill every single person that
it can possibly come across
and so barry ultimately makes the
sacrifice right he says fine
then i will do what i have to do right
in this instance i will rebond myself to
the black racer and i will officially
become the new harbinger of death and
that's what he does right
he combines his power with a black racer
and goes forward accordingly
in this video we are covering dark side
war uh green lantern
the green lantern tie-in for dark side
war this was actually one of my
favorites this was one of my favorite
stories to come
out of the whole dark side war event the
only thing that i didn't like about it
is kind of how it ended and you guys
will see what i'm talking about as we
get closer to it
but in the aftermath of darkseid
basically being killed at the hands of
the anti-monitor
one of the things that we talked about
was that there was nobody left to leave
the parademons
and even within the sphere of apocalypse
itself the planet the dark side lives on
there's a bit of a civil war going on
now that'll be that'll be something that
we cover
uh with the lex luthor tie it we'll talk
about that when we cross that bridge but
the pair of demons that kind of existed
out there have basically consolidated
onto the planet of oak now this is not
arbitrary right it's not doing it just
for the sake of telling a story
it actually makes sense and the reason
why is because ola is home to the
central power battery for the green
lanterns now i would say that in terms
of them going after the green central
power battery as opposed to like the red
lanterns or like the indigo tribe which
i don't think the indigo tribe actually
has a central
central power battery or going after
like the the central power battery of
the orange lantern who is
statistically the most uh the most
powerful of all the lanterns out there
this is just done for the sake of the
story right just because green lantern
was a member of the justice league and
you know
just for the sake of telling a story i
think it would have been cooler if all
the paradigms had gone after the red
lanterns and managed to like take them
all over or something like that but the
important thing here is that with all
the parademons basically arriving on
earth this turned out to be a war of
attrition
right because you have jon stewart who
contacts hal jordan and basically sends
him a message and what he says here is
that this kind of mother box appeared
outside of oah sensing the central power
battery and because the central power
battery was so astronomically powerful
that it basically tried to bond itself
with the power battery which it
ultimately ended up doing the various
green lanterns out there fought against
it as best they could
but they all fell now if the pair of
demons had all attacked owa seemingly at
the same time the green lanterns
actually probably would have stood a
better chance but because of the fact
that it was done
in waves so it would be like a wave of
parademons when they were defeated
another wave of parademons would show up
then another wave in another wave and
another wave it was basically a war of
attrition right it was just kind of this
almost endless onslaught of forces just
coming over and over and over again and
because it was a new wave of parademons
it was
unexhausted parademons facing off
against an exhausted green lantern court
and so as a result of that all these
green lanterns basically ended up
failing they ended up you know being
defeated a lot of them were killed you
know most of the green lanterns were
killed those
those green lanterns who survived and
even the guardians of the universe were
basically taken
by the mother box and they were
conscripted into becoming parademons
themselves so they were transmogrified
into becoming these forces that kind of
helped to bolster their ranks and that's
one of the things that makes darkseid so
dangerous when he was alive anyway and
the nature of the parademons
is this it's not necessarily a
one-to-one ratio like for every person
who falls they become a pair of demon
it's not necessarily like that but i
would say it's probably something like
a one to five ratio so for every five
people who fall
one of them becomes a parademon or
something along those lines which still
is a huge increase in number as time
goes on and so hal jordan is basically
racing to this place as fast as he
possibly can and so
what you end up doing is kind of
sidetracking for a second with this bit
of an inner monologue
between hal jordan and himself and for
the most part if you're reading this
like if you go and you buy this on
comicsology you can largely skip over
this segment but i do want to cover this
because this is going to be a kind of
thing that sort of goes on
intermittently over the course of this
story and so with this little bit of a
discussion it kind of follows
after the death of hal jordan's father
and him and his young as his younger
self basically lighting a candle for
for his father and it's kind of how
jordan coming to terms with the death of
his dad because that's something that it
never truly really happened over the
course of the the green lantern mythos
even when jeff johns was writing it was
always kind of like a background thing
and it was always like i'm gonna learn
lessons about my father and i'm gonna
champion him and he was a great man but
in terms of how jordan actually like
sitting down and saying okay so my dad
died this is something that's basically
governed every decision-making factor of
my life and having to come to terms with
it it's never really
happened before and so that's why this
was so cool and it's one of the reasons
why it was my favorite tie-in here
because it was basically hal jordan kind
of having an inner monologue in inner
discussion with himself and what his
younger child
self does is he kind of asked the
question about church right that his dad
was catholic but his dad never really
took him to church because his dad never
really
never really considered it to be
important and it's one of these things
where it's like
you know i mean he was he never really
believed in god or anything like that
and i guess you kind of would have
thought it would make sense but his
dad's his dad's philosophy was believing
in god doesn't help me when i'm up there
flying right god's not flying my jets
he's not controlling the engines or
anything like that it's myself my
ingenuity my ability to understand what
it is that i'm doing to control all of
that and that's why he's kind of like
you know when his when his plane went
down
god was supposed to catch him right like
isn't that what god's supposed to do
god's supposed to catch us when we fall
and so in essence
how jordan had kind of a existential
crisis
with regards to like his place in the
universe's understanding of god which
usually happens when you're a child
right
which usually happens when you're a
little kid and so this this child
version of himself
begins to lash out now again this is
important here because tom king's the
one writing this and while tom king can
kind of be a little full of himself when
he's writing comics
at this point in time he wasn't he was
he was still a great comic book writer
who hadn't got
got high on his own supply so to speak
you know gotta you know kind of got
addicted to his own success
more or less and so the result of this
is that when it comes to kids
kids usually try to reconcile the
concept of god the only way they know
how and that's why a lot of adults will
experience this crisis on what their
religious
what their religious face really means
in the face of children because kids ask
these questions that adults may have at
some point asked and simply just forgot
but it basically
challenges everything adults believe
right like if god is real then what was
god doing before
before everything was created who
created god it was god always there like
how does all that kind of stuff come
into play and those are pretty basic
questions but those basic questions have
profound impacts
on people's faith and that's what
happens here with hal jordan as a little
kid
why didn't god save my dad if god cares
about us if god truly loves us why
doesn't he save us if people liken god
to parents
and they say well god loving loving us
as humans is like me loving you as a
parent then it's like would you let me
die and if you wouldn't let me die why
would god let me die
why would god just sit up there and
watch why would god just take refuge in
that just kind of
let that thing happen and those are the
kind of struggles that a lot of kids
deal with and they're legitimate
questions to ask right and so hal jordan
as an adult
self kind of chimes in and says well
you're not wrong when your dad died
god really was just watching just like
you were watching right and it's like
god's got no choice
but to watch he has to he has to go over
that moment over and over and over again
he has to just
let those things happen and the reason
why is because god gave humanity free
will
god gave us the ability to create our
own choices to engage in our own actions
of what use would life be if it was
preordained if we knew what was going to
happen or if our actions were somehow
set
in stone if it was just kind of in
existence in that way and that's where
you run into a lot of
i wouldn't really say contradiction but
where you run into a lot of issues in
terms of the the fallibility or the
infallibility of god different things
like that
it's why i always liken god to more of a
prime mover right god just
set things in motion and then whatever
happens happens right he's a kid with an
ant form he's got no kind of plan
whatsoever and so because of that
it's one of these things where that's
kind of the depiction that hal jordan
puts forward here that we as human
beings we have our own will
we have our own choice on what it is
that we do and do not
engage in in this life and that was a
gift given to us by god but it doesn't
mean that if we somehow turn our back on
god
that things are going to get worse for
us right it's not necessarily
you know functioning in that kind of
linear capacity when you believe in god
good things happen when you don't bad
things happen it doesn't necessarily
work that way
then it's just things in this life
happen and sometimes there's nothing we
can do about it it's just the way things
work and so at the end of the day
whether god is truly out there or not
would have no bearing on whether or not
your father died for by whatever manner
and whatever means our father basically
kicked the bucket right he ended up
perishing and so because of that
it's not really our place to blame god
because it wasn't really god's purpose
to come down and save him
anyway right and so again i wouldn't go
as far as to say that
in the aftermath of all this hal jordan
is a born again christian but i will go
as far as to say that how jordan almost
kind of reports this idea that humans
are greater than god and the reason why
is because hal jordan makes this kind of
comparative in saying that if humans
have
free will which is we can do anything we
want with this life that we live
and god is bound to eternally watch and
just simply monitor how things unfold
then god cannot step in right god is
bound by the rules that he created right
which is humans have the ability to live
their lives as they see fit
i cannot intervene that's god's that's
the chains around god and so it's one of
these things where it's like we are
greater than god because we can do
things that god can't do
we can just do whatever we want with our
life god doesn't have that opportunity
he doesn't have that ability and so
because of that where you might think
that we go to church to worship god
the reality is god comes to church to
worship us
because god's envious of us god's
envious of what we can and cannot do
of the kind of freedom that we have in
this life that we live and so that's an
important thing for hal jordan to have
kind of come to terms with because
it removes the idea from like if god
cared he would have saved my dad
you know if i was any measure of a man i
would have saved my dad it kind of cuts
him loose from all that and it says like
sometimes things in this life just
happen and as much as we would love to
stop them and as much as we would love
to blame people for it it just doesn't
work that way right i mean i know you
guys know as americans we're not really
good at taking responsibility for
ourselves we're really good at blaming
people
that's kind of a staple of american
culture right you know if things go
south just blame somebody else and
that's kind of how we do things here
right and so
because of that it's it's kind of uh
turning its back on the nature
of what it means to have been in that
mentality his entire life which is to
say
sometimes things just happen and it's
not as though god has it out for us he's
not trying to punish
us or anything like that it's just the
way things unfold right so
again a bit of an existential crisis
that was going on there now while he was
having that bit of an existential crisis
he was kind of just facing off against
all these parademons on owa and
attacking them as best he could
the reality is that he was just
attacking them head-on so like trying to
kill them using his powers things like
that
the results of this is that the energy
of the central power battery had been
absorbed by the mother box so eventually
his ring will run out of a charge right
and so when it does he'll be
consumed and destroyed and turned into a
parademon if he's not just killed
and so because that how jordan's like
okay if this is the way the game gets
played then we'll play this game right
if what the mother box wants
is somebody to be their god if what
mother box wants is somebody to attain
all that power
everything that makes the the force of
will what it is right the uh the green
lantern central power battery combined
with the power of the source then i will
be that person
i will become that god and he basically
just surrenders himself to this mother
box
slash central power battery and
essentially gains the power of the
source right how jordan definitively
becomes god here specifically he becomes
the god of light now the reality is
that's just a ceremonial title there's
no real differentiation between
like hal jordan here right now as the
god of light and like you know kyle
rainer when he becomes the white lantern
or like superman
1 million when he goes and spins spends
time with the source while santa's a
measurement they are all in effect
the same thing and in fact we're even
told that right that he can do anything
now there's nothing he can't do he can
control the stars he can create life
he can do all kinds of stuff and he
actually does that right because as he
gains this power and as he realizes what
it is that he can and cannot do
he kind of harkens back to the sort of
internal struggle that he has with
himself
which is what is it that i'm that i'm
supposed to do with this kind of power
that i have
sure i could intervene and i could fix
the universe's problems and i could make
everything
okay the problem with this is it's not
my job to do that it's the job of people
to fix
their lives it's the job of people to
get it together it's the job of the
universe to solve its own problems hence
the nature of
free will if i impose my will on other
people then it's going to lead me right
back to where i was before and when i
say that i'm talking about how jordan
when he was like zero hour crisis in
time when he was possessed by parallax
when he had the power of god
he tried to bend the universe to his
womb and in fact he actually did he
blinked it out of existence and brought
it back
right so we've seen what happens when
how jordan becomes consumed by the power
that he has
and when he truly becomes god then he
ends up being bent now at that point in
time he was also possessed so you could
make a legitimate argument that hal
jordan as he exists now
as the god of life is not the same as he
was during zero hour crisis in time back
in the 1990s when he basically wiped out
existence and then brought it back right
you can you can make a good case
that they're not the same thing and he
could actually be a benevolent god here
right he could be a
kind and enlightened god but regardless
he refuses to accept it and so he says
okay fine if this is the case then the
only time i'm going to use this power
is to basically set everything back so
i'm going to undo the pair of demons
arriving here on oahu i'm going to
resurrect everybody who died and set
everything back to the way that it was
before then he in turn instructs the
mother box to destroy itself right and
to place his energy back inside
of the central power battery in essence
nothing comes out of this
nothing comes out of the story hal
jordan doesn't come away any more
powerful than he was
when he when he was you know when he
first went into it right the only real
takeaway from this
is that in this time that he had all
this power he realized what batman was
going to do with the mobius chair and
there's like kind of on a course to
gotham city to stop it
that was the big disappointment here
that was the biggest disappointment
behind all of this
is that it would have been cool to see
how jordan's power elevated to a higher
level now we can largely assume
that jeff johns robert vendetti those
guys who are going to be working on
green lantern that they kind of intended
to do that
anyway but at the time the story was
being written we were what maybe like a
year and a half
two years out from the beginning of like
green lantern like how jordan the green
lantern corps as part of dc rebirth and
the first thing they did in that story
is they had hal jordan craft a ring out
of his own will power right so like it
was cool to see that to see like his
will
elevated to higher levels to see him
becoming more powerful there and and
even then
there really isn't a whole lot of a
story you can tell with a man who
becomes god it's why kyle rainer was the
white lantern god
space jesus messiah guy for a little
while and then lost it all right because
it's great for a story arc but you can't
do anything long term with it because
then you run into like the franklin
richards effect well if something goes
wrong why doesn't hal jordan just fix it
right and so ultimately
you know you end up kind of boxing
yourself into a corner
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion here of dark side war and
there's a couple things that i want to
talk about here
one i kind of like doing these older dc
stories the ones that we just never
covered right that we've heard about
that we've talked about a million times
but never actually covered here like
trinity war um forever evil like we've
never really covered those stories i'm
not going to cover futures in because
that story sucks
i read it and it does blow balls but um
i kind of like you know there's some
stuff from the new 52 and dc comics
that's still
really good that we never really got
around to covering um so i think i might
kind of experiment with that a little
bit
as you guys know i love to experiment
with you guys and find out what you guys
love because i know there's like
500 of you who are replying to comics
we'll watch anything you post rob but
then there's like another however many
hundred thousand people or really just
subscriber count right so like 1.9
million people that i'm trying to appeal
to
and even other people beyond that right
so doing a youtube channel a growing
youtube channel is all about reaching
out to an audience that you have and the
audience you don't have
so uh so with this with the conclusion
of dark side war we kind of pick up in
the aftermath
so to speak of green lantern right it's
kind of the aftermath of pretty much all
the times
we can cover the one for lex luthor the
reality is that nothing really happens
in that tie-in um he just kind of comes
into his own and fully embraces the
power
of like the omega sanction right so like
basically becomes full on dark side for
the most part not
in in a direct sense not in a literal
sense but the power of dark side
and like that's it that's that's really
all you get honestly lex luthor in this
is a lot more interesting than he is in
his own
in his own one shot but uh green lantern
meeting with batman is is really kind of
like trying to talk batman out of the
mobius chair right as we know batman
doesn't want to leave the chair because
in one
and one part of this he's kind of
addicted to it all the knowledge that it
feeds him his ability to fight crime as
he sees it but the other part of that is
that when he tries to leave he
seemingly physically can't it's one of
these interesting scenarios but in the
middle of their conversation
suddenly batman chimes in and says we
need to get out of here we got to go to
wonder woman uh because
right now superman's just kind of losing
his mind now one of the things to
remember
is that when superman was bathed in the
fire pits of apocalypse by lex luthor
in order to help him regain his powers
because the idea was the
pits are fire right there solar pits so
they should rejuvenate superman then he
came out corrupted
right he came out corrupted both in mind
and in body and so his physical powers
his physical abilities aren't really the
same they were before he doesn't really
have the same weaknesses and we'll find
out more about that here in a little bit
but in terms of his mind he's more or
less just kind of bent through chaos and
madness and anger and wrath right now
wonder woman gets the upper hand and
manages to bring that in pretty quickly
by just wrapping it with the lasso of
truth and then just being like who are
you you know and he's like i'm superman
you know and that's basically it
superman's kind of brought back down
and that was really the point i know
that on the surface you can kind of look
at that and just be like well that's
lackluster
this is not designed to be a dan jurgens
death of superman event where like he
comes back with a whole new host of
powers it wasn't really meant to be that
way and one of the things to keep in
mind
is that dc comics was like this story
literally leads directly into dc rebirth
and so we already knew that the
adventures of superman and lois lane by
dan jurgens was already on the table and
it was already being written and being
published so we knew the idea of
blending this version of superman with
the pre-crisis superman was the
intention dc had in the first place and
so it wouldn't really make a whole lot
of sense to give him a whole new set of
powers only to wipe those away then
replace them with the old powers and
then call it a day right to do that
like that right to do it within the span
of like a year or so usually when comics
do that it'll be like a couple years
maybe or so before they before they
shift things up um so it was just a
little too quick of a turnaround the
other part of this
is that you have jessica cruz you've got
cyborg and you've got the master escape
artist mr miracle
basically heading to bel reeve prison
and the reason for this is that while
big bart is creating a distraction for
the guards up top
the idea of of these three guys is to
basically get to the cells
of ultraman and superwoman now ultraman
is superwoman and here's one of the
biggest travesties of dc
comics really like i would say in the
last half of the 20th century is they
never
explored earth 3. they never really
explored the crime syndicate we know
they're doing it now they're releasing a
series coming up soon this focus on
earth 3. and presumably it'll give us a
story of like how earth 3 got to the way
that it was
it'll give us the ins and outs of how
twisted it is and different things like
that uh so it'll be kind of cool to see
that unfold but up to this point
all we knew about these characters is
that like ultraman gets his powers from
kryptonite instead of solar energy and
that superwoman is basically lois lane
right it's just different things along
those lines just these small little
tidbits here and there from this this
alternate reality with regards to power
ring of course that's the a green
lantern ring from earth 3 that's
possessed by the vengeful spirit of
vulthum or at least one aspect of
volthurum so we know little things about
that cyborg is basically great he's like
an evil cyborg in that in that universe
but we don't really know a whole lot and
so
getting some stuff out of this is gonna
be really really cool the problem with
this
is that as jessica cruz has always been
someone who struggled to contain the
power of a ring
one because of the fact that the ring
has a will of its own and is always
trying to dominate the will of jessica
cruz
and two because she lacks so much
confidence and struggles with so much
anxiety that it basically takes away
from her willpower her ability to
actually
overcome fear it basically means the
ring ends up overtaking jessica cruz and
then she's fully under control of
vothume
operating under the name of powerwing
now of course once superman's brought
back down by wonder woman and they meet
with batman then
one of the little things that we get
here and it's not really important
because the nature of the comic is that
the current structure of superman's body
the power
he possesses is breaking him down and is
inevitably killing him that's not really
relevant because we know he doesn't die
just because of the fact that
stories we've covered but uh what they
end up doing is after they they
they kind of get into the cell of
ultraman ultraman is actually in a state
of panic and freaking out because of the
fact that that mobius you know
anti-monitor is currently on earth
and ultraman believes that mobius knows
that he's talking about him right like
anything that could possibly draw the
attention of mobius is enough to scare
the heck out of ultraman and that's one
of the important things to understand
ultraman
for all the power he possessed it really
was just all glitz and glamour right it
was it was just smoke and mirrors that's
all it was it was just kind of like look
at me i'm ultraman i have all this power
but it was just a false confidence right
and that kind of comes to bear in the
fact that while while they faced off
against mobius and he did like
eradicate their world at the same time
if he really was as powerful
and really was as confident as he put
himself off to be then he wouldn't be in
this current state now some of this also
has to do with the fact that because he
has not really consumed any kind of
green kryptonite his powers are
dwindling in the same way that if
superman's not exposed to a yellow sun
his powers will drop off in the same way
but when it comes to
superwoman she's actually pregnant right
she's kind of knocked up now we knew
that was the case kind of going through
just because of the fact that you know
she was
she was technically married to ultraman
but was essentially sleeping behind his
back which kind of makes sense when
you're from earth 3
all you do is just terrible things and
so when that when that happens you have
cyborg who basically tries to override
the ring of jessica cruz that doesn't
work and in fact a portion of his
essence
is trapped inside the ring and then he's
fully corrupted by the power of grid
in essence and then while all that's
going on mobius finally emerges in what
i would refer to as his perfect form
right now when mobius finally emerges
you end up having the cell wall kind of
blown open
and that's when owlman shows up right
the earth 3 version of batman who's
basically like an evil version of bruce
the reality of this is even when you
take into account dark knight's medal by
scott snyder
i still say owlman is probably one of
the coolest versions of batman who
exists out there again we don't really
know a whole lot about him we don't
really see a whole lot about his
character we will as time goes on but of
course
having this green crypt tonight in the
possession of superman which was
technically created by lex luthor or
captured by lex luthor
one it doesn't affect superman in his
current corrupted form which is one of
the things that's kind of given to us is
that superman's not vulnerable to
kryptonite in this current form
two when it's given to uh ultraman it's
like a drug
like literally it's like his version of
crack like he's scratching you know
y'all got any more of him kryptonites
like that's basically what it is
right and so as soon as he consumes it
he kind of reverts back to his normal
self and the whole
the whole meeting that goes on here the
reason why these two groups are together
is because mobius was powerful enough to
eradicate earth 3 and he's powerful
enough to eradicate the main dc universe
the only way for these heroes to come
out on top or at least these characters
anyway to come out on top
is for them to team up right for the
villains of the crime syndicate to team
up with the heroes of the justice league
now understand
neither one of these groups is too keen
on this idea right neither one of them
is like yeah i mean
it's cool they're pretty cool guys right
i mean i'd have a beer with superman
says owlman that's never gonna happen
right like
they they don't really want to work
together but the reality is
they stand more to lose by working
separately than they than they do by
working in unison
now while that's happening the
anti-monitor is kind of fulfilling its
purpose right we can just call them
anti-monitor
some people might want to split hairs
and call them mobius it really is all
just the same thing right tomato tomato
and the whole point behind mobius as he
exists here he just
relishes in destruction and eradicating
life right just killing and destroying
things right kind of like
an evil benevolent god and it was really
just jeff john's way
of taking the anti-monitor as we knew
him and tying him directly into mobius
and kind of bridging the gap between the
original
crisis on affinidar's depiction of
anti-monitor and the way we see him here
especially when it came to new readers
but even those who were asking questions
coming in the aftermath of like sinestro
core war and things along those lines
and so you have the various heroes who
show up here and do what they can and
then you have the crime syndicate who
are just like all we want to do is kill
mobius because he eradicated our world
and for the most part they're doing what
they can where they can
but they are quite literally fighting
the uh fighting a guy with the power of
a god right a man with the power to
eradicate entire
universes now it's not one of these
things that's on the scale of like
the living tribunal where he just snaps
his fingers and the universe is gone
right it certainly takes time
and it takes a lot of energy but the
important takeaway from this is he's
well beyond the power of the justice
league and so where you end up having
like jessica cruz possessed by volthume
who's doing her thing
that one of the things that happens here
is that you end up seeing the green
lantern corps arrive now the green
lantern corps showing up here is really
more of like returning the favor of how
jordan's showing up to uh owa and then
basically saving the green lantern corps
from
what was essentially their deaths and
then it's kind of undoing everything
using a super powerful ring so that's
one of the reasons why we
why we cover that particular tie-in at
least in order to make this moment make
sense but understand here even the
arrival of the green lantern corps is
not enough to really
turn the tide of the battle and in fact
like there's this massive amount of
energy that the anti-monitor lets off
that wipes out a huge portion of the of
the green lantern core that's here
and the rings immediately take off and
start looking for replacements now while
this battle with mobius for the
anti-monitor is currently taking place
steve trevor is suddenly snatched up by
grail and the important thing about that
is grail actually has a plan for steve
trevor
and a particular intention she that she
wants as far as using him goes
but while that goes on you have mobius
who ultimately attacks ultraman
and basically talks a little bit of
smack to him and then starts to kill him
and where the the
where the flash could step in and the
flash could actually intervene
and save the life of ultraman the
reality is he can't
and the reason why is because while he
does have a new host of powers
he and the black racer are for the most
part kind of working in unison
not in the sense that like they have the
same goal but in the sense that like
one will is able to sort of dominate the
other depending on the circumstance and
because the entire existence of the
black racer
is to monitor and wait for death uh and
to basically whisk those individuals who
are supposed to die away to perdition
it doesn't move and it doesn't allow
barry allen to move so barry allen
cannot step in and save
ultraman despite the fact that ultraman
being there would be a huge boon for the
superheroes
in this in this battle because he's
basically an alternate reality version
of superman right so it's like having
two superman on the chessboard you could
do a lot of damage with these guys now
there is a bit of a saving grace that
comes in
in the sense that once mobius kills
ultraman then you have the arrival of
lex luthor who basically seizes control
of all the parademons right who's taking
over the pair demons of apocalypse and
then is using them
as his own personal army now something
else to understand lex luthor has all
the power of dark side here he's got all
this power of dark side but one of the
things that jeff
johns really sort of sort of gives us is
this idea that while we looked at the
beginning of dark side war and we
basically saw dark side and mobius
facing off against each other
and mobius getting the upper hand but
seemingly there being a kind of
stalemate there that what it looks like
is that in this situation once he's
basically
freed of the influence of the anti-life
equation that mobius
is basically in his perfect form right
he's exceedingly powerful
now the other part of this though is we
kind of have to take lex luthor at face
value
lex luthor despite how intelligent he is
and how capable he is
this is the first time he's really
wielding a power like this
and so it would be pretty disingenuous
to say that like lex luthor is on par
with darkseid
not in a perfect sense right darkseid
wielded his power for eons eons and eons
and eons neons he explored every facet
of the omega sanction and knew exactly
how to use it with surgical precision
when it comes to somebody like lex
luthor he's just using it as best he can
right
it's blast of energy it's the omega
beams right it's the kind of general
thing that he's seen darkseid do
because he's still sort of learning how
to use this power as he has it and so
this this kind of lack of experience
with the ability he wields
basically comes to bear when he faces
off against the against mobius and there
is a kind of
uh you know stalemate to a degree but
it's also pretty obvious that mobius is
gonna get the upper hand in this bit of
a conflict here because one of the
things to notice
is that when it comes to the fight
between these two lex luthor is largely
resigning himself to physical attacks
as opposed to using more ranged attacks
against somebody like anti-monitor which
proved to be more successful with
darkseid right darkseid used that
exceedingly well to his advantage
also because darkseid was more
battle-hardened right he was more like
he was more of a
master strategist when it came to combat
it doesn't mean lex luthor cannot be
that way but there's a difference
between a person who's been fighting
wars for millions and millions of years
and a person who's been doing it for
like
35 years or so and so while that battle
is taking place kind of jumping back
over to batman and to wonder woman and
superwoman and jessica cruz
or really vulthum if you want to call
her that batman using the mobius chair
starts to realize the plan of what it is
that grail shooting for
but also the significance of the baby
that that superwoman is knocked up with
and so what is up happening is that once
she begins the birthing process
and starts to have this baby that as it
comes out and as
as it's emerged it comes out as a baby
the way that you would expect it to
but grail suddenly arrives on the scene
here and that's when like black racer
flash is like you should all run
and again the whole reason why he's not
moving is he's basically waiting for
death he's waiting for somebody to die
right like a
a person or people are going to die here
and the black racer is simply waiting
for his time
to pull him away and so what ends up
happening is that when the baby's born
from superwoman that is one of these
things where like
everybody kind of starts to panic right
and that's because one
this baby is basically a weapon that uh
that that superwoman intends to use
two it's actually something that grail
intends to take and three
steve trevor's back but steve trevor is
completely imbued with the power of
what is an effect the anti-life equation
combined with whatever power she was
able to garner from darkseid and so
steve trevor showing up here
he immediately eradicates mobius right
just like that
mobius is completely and totally
destroyed now the reason why this
happens
is because if steve trevor is infused
with anti-life
then seemingly it'd be totally possible
for him to just eradicate
anybody who's living right to basically
just destroy their essence but something
else that goes on here is that superman
attacked mobius prior to this point and
basically just dispelled all the
apocalypse and energy within his body
that was something that i kind of missed
when it happened um that does need to be
said for those of you guys who are kind
of curious why superman looks the you
know looks
back to normal so that was that part's
pretty pretty straightforward but in
effect
with modius basically gone and
eradicated in a pretty
lackluster way if i'm being honest with
you guys the biggest threat now turns
directly to steve trevor and then grail
now there's also another part of this
plan that grail has
which is pretty amazing right it's a
pretty genius plan that she has for
herself
single-handedly she goes through and
basically just
takes out every single member of the
justice league and even when the green
lantern comes the green lantern corps
come in and they try to basically lock
her down in a cage
because of the fact that her weapon was
basically forged by hades of the
underworld it can cut through pretty
much anything and he could
you can even cut through hard-like
constructs meaning that she can't she
basically just cannot be taken down
by these forces of of of the green
lantern court
and so ultimately we end up learning
that with the child of
superwoman when she basically brings
this kid to bear and then starts using
him as the weapon that she intended to
then he can basically shout the word
shazam now technically it's mazaz right
it's just the reversal of shazam which
makes sense because earth 3 is the
reversal of the main dc universe uh and
basically he has the power of shazam but
the
but it's a little bit different in the
sense that unlike shazam where he
basically goes through and like gains
powers from other people the baby can
take powers from other people and so the
intention of superwoman is to basically
use her baby to siphon off the power of
pretty much anybody else
including shazam from the main dc
universe and gain his powers in turn and
so when that happens
steve trevor basically launches an
attack to take out wonder woman at the
direction of grail
despite his desire not to do so and when
that takes place
you have grail who kills superwoman and
then uses the baby and shouts
mazaz and then in turn that basically
splits the flash and it splits uh the
the black racer into
into two separate beings when the flash
runs directly in front of the blast that
was meant to kill wonder woman now
splitting the two in half
basically sends the flash out of the
equation because now the black racer is
directly after him right so flash just
kind of has to leave in order to keep
himself from being killed and that just
sort of continually follows suit right
that there's a little bit of a reprieve
here that the superheroes get
trying to figure out what to do now for
the most part jessica cruz
also ends up being attacked and it's
believed that she's basically dead when
she's cut down
by uh by the by the black racer but one
of the things that had kind of gone on
here
is that within the ring itself and even
with jessica cruz when cyborg had
downloaded or at least tried to make
contact with the ring and downloaded his
essence into it and both thumb had taken
over
taking over jessica cruz that her
consciousness sort of existed as a
background character right within the
ring itself and kind of having this
conversation with cyborg and watching
everything go on and watching the
various heroes
seemingly lose in almost every
conceivable way that she ultimately
overcame her fear when she stepped out
and so jumping in front of and facing
off against the black racer the way that
she did
basically allowed her to overcome her
fear of death and if you're not afraid
of dying you're not afraid of anything
right so basically she'd overcome her
fear in her entirety which was a pretty
significant
moment because that's how she became a
full-on green lantern right which of
course we know
from our coverage of the green lantern
stories uh post-dark side war
and so following that it really kind of
comes down to grail who exercises the
final moment of her plan right the final
intention of her plan and what she ended
up doing
was basically following this prophecy
that said that the first person who
stepped foot on themyscira was
considered quote unquote the chosen one
and so bonding the anti-life equation to
steve trevor was really
nothing more than one allowing her to
destroy mobius but two
to basically just kind of keep it safe
right to sort of keep it guarded because
she knew
that none of the members of the justice
league would actively kill steve trevor
and so when that happens she basically
ends up taking the baby of wonder woman
has it shout shazam and then takes the
anti-life equation directly out of steve
trevor in the process and so the baby
basically absorbs the anti-life equation
and is totally reborn as dark side and
so when darkseid reemerges here
that it's not really dark side as we
know it's dark side bent to the will of
grail because of the fact that he's kind
of dominated by the anti-life equation
he does whatever she tells him to and
that's exactly what happens like she's
just like killed them all right so
basically it's now dark side and grail
facing off against the uh
facing off against the justice league
and so because of the fact that there's
so
little chance for success here hal
jordan does the only thing he can do
here right with batman basically being
kind of knocked off the mobius chair
being removed from the mobius chair
because of the fact that batman's not
directly willing to remove himself from
the mobius chair what he needs is the
willpower to do so
and so how jordan takes his green
lantern ring and basically attaches it
to batman's finger and says the universe
needs you more than me right i'm just a
guy who flies and fights like i'm pretty
capable and i've got a lot of willpower
but we need your mind we need your
willpower we need your ability to
function as a cohesive member of the
team
not some crazy guy sitting on a chair
telling us that we're screwed and so
because of that when that happens
batman full-on becomes a green lantern
but it's not something that really
that doesn't really become a mainstay
here and it makes sense because this
doesn't really happen until the end of
the story
if it had happened at the beginning i
would say batman would definitely have a
more prominent role but batman being a
green lantern here is just kind of
designed to help him one remove himself
from the chair
and then two to basically find a way to
help the superheroes win
now owlman of course ends up basically
saying okay fine like
everything's done time for plan b bonds
himself to the chair uh basically takes
the
the essence of grid from earth 3
downloads it from cyborg and then
leaves and they basically ended up
putting it inside of a of a bot that was
created by lex luthor and so
from there cyborg basically goes back to
his normal self and so alamann basically
bails out right he immediately takes off
and i imagine most of you guys know
exactly what happens to him the other
part of this is that because the ritual
was cast by
by grail the only way for the ritual to
be undone is for grail to undo it
herself which is something that she's
not remotely interested in doing or so
it would seem what is up happening here
instead
is that the the the lasso of truth by
wonder woman
is basically wrapped around grail and
basically compels her to tell the truth
right compels her to be honest and when
she does there's
this really really human moment that
happens here where she legitimately
believes that she cannot be good right
she cannot be
a good human being that she has to
effectively be a villain and so when
that happens like her mother tells her
like you can do good right you can be
an actual great person and so she says
do the thing that you that you know you
don't want to do but you know you have
to do and she's like
kill me right like marina black is just
like use your use your power and kill me
now the reality of this
is that when grill does this one it does
pierce marina black and killer
but two it also kills dark side now the
reason why this blast kills dark side is
because it's not dark side in its most
pure form right it's not dark side as
we're traditionally used to seeing him
instead it's just kind of dark side the
guy who's kind of a resurrected baby
right so again
coming into his own containing the full
totality of darkseid's power had not
really been achieved at that point the
other part of this is that because
jessica cruz had in effect
sacrificed her life in order to save the
life of barry allen and basically
overcome her fear of death and by
extension her fear of pretty much
everything else the ring of old thumb of
course
is ultimately destroyed but she's bonded
with a green lantern ring and is chosen
to become a full-on member of the green
lantern court now this was kind of like
the conclusion of the jessica cruz story
arc if there really is such a thing in
dc comics uh jeff johns had paid special
attention to her character when he
introduced her in
the idea of her and simon bats was to
introduce like new green lantern
characters that dc could exclusively
focus on the problem was at the time
that they were introduced
dc didn't have any intention or hadn't
even conceived a dart of dc rebirth by
the time this story came to an end it's
dc rebirth comes next and that's why you
don't really see a whole lot of
attention paid to jessica cruz and simon
baz in relation to like everything else
going on
in the dc landscape is part of rebirth
instead they were kind of shuffled after
their own story in the green lantern's
comic book by sam humphries which was
amazing don't get me wrong it didn't
it did not suck it was an amazing book
it was probably some of the best green
lantern storytelling that i think i'd
ever seen like between robert van der's
green lantern run
and sam humphrey's green lantern run it
was crazy good like it was just
ridiculously amazing
especially when you got the origin of
vulthu if you guys are interested in
that you can check the green lantern
playlist down in the description
and yes we will do more green lantern
don't worry i'm not gonna leave you guys
hanging forever
but in essence it's really just kind of
picking up the pieces
the black racer is basically out of the
picture now doing its thing right it's
just kind of off doing black racer stuff
whatever the black racer does
uh and the justice league's just kind of
picking up the pieces from this this
massive conflict there is a bit of an
epilogue in the sense that with grail
having killed her mom but because the
the essence of dark side was kind of
dispersed that it still exists in this
sort of child form
and so dark side will emerge at some
future point in time but the big
takeaway from this
is there's two major things that come
out of this the first is
that lex luthor basically sits on the
throne of apocalypse as quote unquote
the new dark side
this matters because when you go into
action comics and superman rebirth those
of you guys who are reading the point
where you know dc rebirth superman
never trusted lex luthor because he
always believed he would become darkseid
that's where this comes from
that's where that particular thing comes
from is this particular moment in the
comic right here
the other thing the other big thing that
comes out of this is the epilogue which
directly set the stage for dc rebirth in
the sense that on the moon
you've got owl man who's basically there
alongside metron the two of them kind of
having a conversation of sorts and what
is
going on here is that while the two of
them are talking that suddenly
you end up having this realization from
uh from owlman that like he basically
says he's here
and while we don't really get an
explanation or didn't at the time
suddenly you basically end up seeing
owlman destroyed in the same way that
you saw dr manhattan kill rorschach at
the end of watchmen right so that's what
people were referencing when they were
talking about these little clues and
things like that that dr manhattan's in
the dc universe now uh and of course
this all directly leads
into dc universe rebirth number one like
the one shot comic that sort of set
everything off but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
this